foreign
[Music]
everybody Welcome to the mix 2023 our
first show of the new year and the least
pretentious Showcase in the game My name
is Justin Woodward I'll be your host
today co-founder of the mix interbang
entertainment and black voice and gaming
as well as a proud advisor on the black
game developer fund the mix is all about
the games the creative teams behind them
culture of game development and
showcasing dope games and updates from
games you are definitely going to look
forward to playing as a team of game
developers and a Game Dev myself we have
been in the thick of it for years
working with hundreds of developers and
finding the best ways to get their game
seen to folks who want to see their
Visions come to life you are going to be
a part of it make sure to follow the
develop helpers you like through their
socials you could find all of their
games on the website media Indie
exchange.com and check us out on Twitter
at Indie exchange everywhere else at
media Indie exchange as well as
subscribe to our twitch Channel and
YouTube channels as well the developers
and Publishers on this stream have
blessed us with steam keys to games from
their catalog when you see the following
QR code pop up grab your phones take a
flick for your chance to grab a great
game once again we have teamed up with
the Exquisite Folks at valve to showcase
our stream on their platform in order to
support the devs be sure to check out
the mix event page on Steam where you
can wish list or play the games that are
featured in this event
we want to give a huge shout out to all
of our sponsors for helping to make this
thing happen PlayStation raw Fury and
Wilson suncini all of our other sponsors
who are equally as awesome here they are
and all of their Glory shout out to our
broadcasting partners for supporting
this showcase and the developers on the
stream as well twitch IGN Gamespot steam
you guys are fantastic salute to all the
developers who are participating that
have all contributed their games and
resources to making this thing possible
after the Showcase be sure to stay tuned
for another episode of black voice and
gaming hosted by Khalif and Destiny it's
going to be a good show enough with all
the intro stuff let's get right into it
for our first set of games we're going
to introduce some exclusive trailers as
well as new gameplay footage starting
with a new action title and head into an
update on heart machine games latest
revealed game and follow that up with
the game that a warming your taste buds
with some nice savory soup
let's get started
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
the world of Dreams reverie was invaded
by nightmares the Ravens watch Ravens
that protect reverie called upon fallen
heroes of fairy tales and legends to
join forces to defend the world from the
developers of the acclaimed curse of the
Dead Gods this upcoming action roguelike
is set in a dark fantasy tale and
playable Solo or in online co-op up to
four players
you play as Twisted versions of old folk
fairy tale Heroes Little Red Riding Hood
the Pied Piper the Snow Queen choose
from six popular characters each with
their own play styles Master their
abilities and fight back against the
evil corrupting the world More Heroes
will be added during the Early Access
explore vast and ever-changing chapters
with their own cast of enemies and
quests
collect dream shards to buy power-ups
and magical objects from the Sandman and
fight hordes of enemies to level up each
Hero has multiple abilities at their
disposal
first is the trait a hero's core
mechanic that defines their gameplay
for instance Scarlet transforms into the
wolf at night Beowulf carries a worm
that empowers his next attacks Aladdin
can call the genie the lamp to make a
wish
each hero also has a dash three
different attacks and one defensive
ability
finally unlocking their ultimate ability
when reaching level 5. these abilities
are improved with the experience you
gain from battles each level up makes
you stronger and gives you the
opportunity to choose a new upgrade that
improves one of your abilities all of
this makes each of the six Heroes
completely unique and gives each run a
different flavor play them to find out
in typical roguelike fashion each run is
an attempt at defeating the horde of
nightmares if they get you your run is
over and you'll need to restart but
don't lose hope each run is an
opportunity to unlock better magical
objects and upgrades for your next
attempt
as well as learning more about the
heroes and World stories Ravens watch
offers countless hours of challenges
both in Solo and in four-player Co-op
find the best combination of Heroes each
with their own intricacies and make
those synergies count as the challenge
scales with the number of players join
now and follow us along the Journey of
making the next roguelike jet
[Music]
hey this is Lee from Alien trap games
and we're showing gameplay of our next
game gun hit on roguelike FPS we're
releasing later this year
[Music]
gunhead is a sequel to our 2017 side
score the cryptarch it takes the same
fast-faced gameplay and strategic
planning but now it's a first person
shooter
[Music]
in good head you take the role of a
space pirate crew tasked with looting
alien ships here I am starting my own
ship further in the game and selecting
the next ship to board
so before I board the enemy ship I can
bring up the map to decide my strategy
to attack every ship and gun head is
randomly generated and there's a variety
of different enemy defense systems on
board my goal here is to take out the
core system but to do that I first need
to take out the shield system protecting
it I might also want to take out other
defensive systems on the ship like the
factory system which is creating new
enemies there's also two repair systems
on this ship which were quickly repair
destroyed systems so I need to take that
out first
each level and gun ahead is a variety of
these defense systems which interact and
make each ship different
to start the mission I'll go into the
hangar to enter a mech suit each mech
suit serves the different ability and
loadouts with this one having a jet pack
and old weapons I can test my weapons
here and use the loadout console to
change my logo in the loader console I
can select any of the technology I've
found on ships because this ship has two
repair systems called crypto remote
detonation pod to take them both out at
the same time
once in space I can fly around the
entire ship and choose the door to
attack from I'm born for the repair
system first so I'll enter beside one to
drop a remote ball
the goal of gun ahead was to create a
roguelike game with intense
moment-to-moment action but still
require planning and strategy because
every level has a random different
combination of enemy systems on it they
need to be approached completely
differently
here I'm trying to take out the Sentry
system but since I didn't take out the
alarm system before I triggered the
alarm and now more enemies down my
position
I can also plan my attack right to find
health systems on board and new
technology like weapons and items
here I'm using an EMP blast to stun
enemies it's an attractor beam to grab
an enemy forward another one
after destroying the shield system I can
destroy the core to finish the bishop
after a successful Mission bonuses are
given by a contractors based on our
objectives I can then use that cache to
research new technology to add to my
logo
each enemy ship type in gunhead has
different systems and enemies on board
with some having large bosses as their
core system to put out
Love At First Bite
a reality dating show starring you
sexiest monsters will compete for your
affection what's the worst that could
happen
I just like Drac because you know we're
taking one of the most beloved
characters in fiction All of fictionally
Dracula right to see how drach plays off
the different characters and to really
put yourself in directions you you know
feel a bit like you're playing as the
Prince of Darkness right so Drac is
unique in the way that he is very open
to characters I feel he just wants to
help every character that he comes
across and just really eager to learn I
feel like he just wants to learn and
help people out as he travels through
the game it was wonderful to see a game
Explorer what if he was kind of past
this Prime and he really hadn't found
true love and we look at him as the
ultimate Gothic boyfriend but I think
it's also his journey of you know he's
been heartbroken he's been defeated
humiliated and just the way he is able
to come back from that and the
willingness to take other people's
advice take Grimm's advice and and let
the past be passed Grimm's got got some
baggage and you know Grim is used to
destruction and he's got the opportunity
to create and when he's creating the
show it kind of gets the better of him
and we see a different side To Grim
later on the characters are really
fleshed out and they all have one or two
like personal turmoil things that you
get to uncover through pursuing their
storyline a little bit more so you can
uh romance many many characters in this
game it's it's very similar to The
Bachelor Style TV show right so you have
to vote people off at different points
so you have to kind of build
relationship with a handful of
characters that you like most and it
will funnel other characters out you
vote them off when Drac has finally
moved on and is ready to become who he
used to be that's what we're going to
punch you in the gut
it's gonna hurt but again we go back to
meaningful choice and let the player
figure out what that all means in the
end because you're going to be faced
with some difficult choices
let's get the show on the road
[Music]
foreign
yo hyper light breaker is definitely
putting hype and Hyper and gun head is
looking super solid and frantic just
looking at sopa makes me want something
hot and tasty because it is definitely
cold in these streets right now make
sure to wish list the games on Steam
Playstation Xbox Nintendo everywhere
they're available pre-order them support
these devs next up we'll be looking at
games that will take you on a journey
for Adventures into narrative
storytelling let's go
[Music]
ha ha ha
when I think back to my childhood
everything becomes blurry
I know I used to go to my grandma's
house and double down each summer
we'll have fun the two of us
but these memories have faded and lost
their color
this is wow
my escapades along the river this
is the discovery of incredible Treasures
the people
[Music]
the smell of breakfast in the early
morning
and you haven't seen anything yet
gone
um grandma
this place is
a very special place
[Music]
all I remember is that I miss daldanya
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
directions
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
all right
he's dead
hide somewhere and wait I'll find you
there's no time either jump or I push
you
now woman
Lord I beg of you you can't let me die
[Music]
greetings valued employee and welcome to
the Ringo Corporation here there is no
greater dignity than work
[Music]
live
to work
[Music]
it is my privilege to introduce to you
your lifelong assignment it would be
your job to sort samples
there is no need to question the samples
the samples are important and as such
you are important
I have no doubt that you will give 110
after all productivity is in your nature
Ringo appreciates that arrested mind
empowers the grind that is why as an
employee citizen you will also be given
access to the finest shopping and
entertainment
it is your duty to put your money back
into the economy when it comes to the
corporation
growth is strength
during your time here Rogue workers may
try to entice you into betraying your
beloved employer
but I am sure of your loyalty
you know that work is dignity you know
that Ringo provides well then valued
employee are you ready to begin your
exciting New Life
good luck
work hard
[Applause]
[Music]
hi my name is Frederick and I am a
co-founder of dimpro studio and the
design director of Fireball game Bramble
the Mountain King
Bramble the Mountain King is an action
adventure platformer based on dark
Nordic folklore and set in a Swedish
environment
[Music]
our first idea when we started to create
the game was to do something with
Vikings but that has already been done
so well
foreign
[Music]
we chose to base our game around Nordic
folklore because we wanted to tell a
story that is very close to our Nordic
hearts that hasn't been told before with
Bramble we want to introduce these dark
stories to the rest of the world as well
the stores we tell him Bramble are all
stories we ourselves heard as children
stories about creatures that lurks in
nature that our parents told us to keep
us out of the forest at night
some of the creatures are dark and scary
but some of them are kind and filled
with love
let me tell you a little bit more about
one of the kind ones
this is lemus
and he might look scary but he is
actually very kind
in his whole life he has looked for a
friend but his appearance scare most
away
but when he finds a friend he will be
loyal a little bit like a happy puppy
[Music]
Lamas is actually inspired from a
creature in a painting by John Bauer
but not all creatures are as kind as
lemus
we all heard stories about a creature in
the lake learning children to him with
his melodies
depending on where you grew up in Sweden
Denmark Norway or Finland you have heard
different stories about this creature
called nekin
we have collected a lot of these stories
and added our own dark twist to it and
we look forward to seeing you experience
it
we hope you are excited to meet lemus
nekand and many more creatures when
Bramble the Mountain King is releasing
on April 27th on PC PS4 PS5 Nintendo
switch and Xbox series X slash S
foreign
[Music]
we've worked hard these long years
haven't you and I
[Music]
don't you deserve something for your
devout work for the cause
doesn't it Angry you to see the suits
take all the profits from your labor
perhaps you'd like to worship a prophet
rather than worshiping prophets
attention
immediately
whoever enters these Halls will be
equalized whether they want it or not
wouldn't you love to see their blood on
the factory for you Mom today recycle
into a new comrade
glory to Escrow glory to the factory
glory to you
the twists and turns behind two Falls
has me definitely wanting to jump in two
feet first in the game one thousand X
resist looks visually spectacular so
many great story driven titles again
make sure to wish list those games
everywhere it is possible steam Xbox
wherever
help the devs out the next set of games
are sequels and updates to beloved neo
classic Indie franchises as well as some
new games that will scratch that
strategy building and simulation itch
let's go
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
ah
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is Tamarack Trail
where you as a member of a secret
society known as the sturgeon Lodge work
to uncover the mystery behind a
corruption spreading throughout the
Canadian Shield
as a member of the lodge it's your duty
to track down the source of this
corruption and put a stop to it
for each run you have a choice between
three unique characters each with their
own distinct set of abilities
the detective magician and tracker are
the First characters you'll be
introduced to then click on the map in
the cabin to begin your journey welcome
to the trail randomly generated each
time you Embark you'll encounter events
enemies campsites and treasure all of
which provide helpful items bonuses and
currency to enhance your preferred play
style
combat is turn-based using a handful of
dice instead of an ability bar adding an
element of skill to a familiar and
comfortable battle system
you will engage with a wide variety of
enemies on the trail all with their own
unique behaviors and attack patterns
which keep you constantly on your toes
and making adjustments to your build in
order to best adapt to the situation
ahead of you rolling the dice manually
works just like a board game hold and
release your Buffs and drag and drop
your attacks onto your chosen Target
[Music]
the auto roll feature instead both
options are equally viable in combat we
encourage you to try both and find a
style of play that suits you best we'll
even have controller support on launch
for extra flexibility you'll also be
earning currency to upgrade your Lodge
and your character permanently
what you're seeing here is still a demo
build in active development in the final
game you'll follow the trail to a
variety of different environments from
the secluded Woodlands of the Canadian
Shield to the decaying ruins of a
mysterious ghost cult
and work towards the discovery of a
corruption spreading throughout the
world
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
overthrowing your despotic ruler has
never been more fun than in let's
Revolution
farcical debut game from award-winning
Animation Studio buck and the Sonic
maestros at ant food
let's Revolution is a roguelite puzzle
mashup that blends the rules of
Minesweeper with procedurally generated
mazes
embark on a perilous journey to hide and
seek as you uncover the path to your
goals chase down the Cowardly King
through the Fantastical Realms of b-bomb
while facing off against his army of
deadly minions
gear up with powerful Loot and gain
amazing abilities
prepare for the final showdown in b-bomb
City
who's your hero from six unique classes
each with their own play style and
abilities are you a Powerhouse like the
charger who unleashes devastating
attacks but must skillfully manage their
energy while rushing into battle or do
you prefer the acrobatic stylings of the
Shadow who uses cunning items like smoke
bombs to outwit and outmaneuver
if you believe knowledge is power you'll
love the Oracle who uses magic to reveal
extra information about the world so you
could navigate with Superior logic take
a trip through the beautifully
Illustrated world of bebomb from the
harsh deserts of flocks through the Lush
and mysterious jungles of cymbidium to
the Serene floating islands of saffron
along the way you'll encounter a diverse
cast of memorable characters
from the King and his boot licking
lackeys to the colorful shopkeepers that
help you along the way
each character is brought to life
through expressive hand-drawn animation
and cheeky dialogue whether you're a
seasoned gamer craving a challenge or a
casual player looking to overthrow the
monarchy with ease the game inspired
mechanics keep the focus on the fun of
learning new skills
rather than crunching stats and with
over 100 abilities and items to try out
there's always something new to discover
this summer fight for what's right give
the king the Royal boot in let's
Revolution
wishlist now on Steam and check out
let's revolution.com for all the deets
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back just a reminder to make
sure to subscribe to our twitch and
YouTube Pages for more announcements
trailers and interviews as well as
follow us on Twitter and our other
socials in order to find out more about
these awesome new games and support the
culture of game development coming up we
have a chunk of games from our friends
at thunderfool that range from a new
reveal from Team meet and an update on
the up-and-coming steam World Universe
title
I can't wait
[Music]
foreign
fortunately it's nothing me and my box
here can't handle
so make sure to have them ready before
we start digging too deep with our great
arsenal the guards will make short work
of these bugs
mmm look at them pop however before
Excavating any of the rocket pieces on
the lower levels I do recommend you
build a more permanent defense
[Music]
and lucky for us and that's so lucky for
them we have bombs there is no enemy
they can't handle but
gross his strength over time
make sure to expand your defenses run
the risk of being overrunning
it's too many of them fall back a safe
fall back
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Dr robotnik's mean being machine and Dr
Mario was such great games I love the
homage being paid to those titles
wordless is very euphoric and sounds
incredible looking forward to hearing
more from the thunderfield team and the
devs they have been working with and
supporting make sure to show those devs
some love by wish listing liking and
sharing those games on them socials
moving forward our next category is
focus on action adventure titles that
take you into the Realms of Wonder and
Exploration with interesting World
building and immersion as well as unique
narrative design and fantastic Journeys
foreign
[Music]
a game designer for Dave the diver let's
take a look at some gameplay and content
in the Early Access version of our game
Dave the diver plunges players into an
oceanic Adventure set in a real marine
environment of a blue hole with over 200
different kinds of sea creatures now for
some of the exploration gameplay
Dave will explore the deep sea within
this blue hole and come into contact
with all kinds of sea creatures some for
capturing to make sushi and even some
more aggressive sea creatures to be wary
of some you'll want to avoid but some
may be worth hunting
some creatures you will befriend that
will set you on New Missions to take on
other peaceful creatures you can engage
with in other ways like taking their
picture
once Dave's long day of diving is over
his night begins where he takes the fish
he captured during the day and sells
them as Sushi to make money sometimes to
special customers
Dave will work hard running back and
forth serving customers Sushi beer
and even tea
but eventually he's going to need a
helping hand
this is where staff comes in to take
some of the load off Dave and to get
more money more efficiently he's going
to want to upgrade his dishes with the
help of Master Chef Pancho
[Music]
and here's a glimpse of just one of the
bosses Dave will encounter unique bosses
will come in all shapes and sizes
fighting bosses won't be like hunting
just ordinary fish with his harpoon
to take on big bosses Dave will want to
have the right equipment and the right
weapons
Dave will need the help of weapon Master
Duff to get the right weapons for the
job
this is where having the right equipment
becomes such a vital part of the
gameplay and where the money Dave makes
from his nighttime activities become
important
the money he makes from selling sushi at
the restaurant he will spend on
upgrading his oxygen tank and diving
equipment which he will need to take on
various intimidating bosses
Dave will encounter bosses mostly at the
end of each chapter
each boss will have its own unique
characteristics and weak points that
Dave will have to figure out
not all bosses are based on strength of
Brute Force though so you will need to
figure out what makes each boss tick
but crafting weapons and upgrading can
definitely give you an advantage
so if you find yourself not fully
prepared you always have the option to
retreat get the right equipment then
come back later
we hope you enjoyed the look at the
gameplay for Dave the diver
Early Access is out now on Steam and the
full game will release in the first half
of 2023. the full version will have more
story chapters more systems many more
efficient sea creatures to find so we
look forward to giving you the best
experience possible when the game
launches soon
[Music]
thank you
no
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
what what
foreign
looking good
[Music]
foreign
wildmender is an open world survival
gardening game where you grill plants to
survive and thrive in a deserted World
adventure with your friends to find new
resources and uncover floss secrets I'm
Cameron designer at Muse games and this
is our next game wildmender
I'm Matt content manager at quali so we
find ourselves at a small Desert Spring
surrounded by nothing but sand dunes and
dead trees but there is water here and
with that we can work to turn this
Barren land into a paradise
yeah as you
get your garden dig channels and unblock
Springs you'll be able to make some
truly massive Gardens some people like
to make large Farms full of grain while
we've seen other players make beautiful
nature walks with all sorts of bridges
and streams
this desert isn't all just sand and dust
though but once I go further afield if
we want to find something truly special
the Salt Flats bring new dangers like
this corrupted Outpost surrounded by
wraiths I think we'll need some help for
this one
making friends with the creatures who
survived the destruction of this world
will definitely help like these little
Spirits as well
great job not everything in this world
is out to get us though we can also
befriend animals and Spirits to help us
on our journey
we've got some new seeds and a cute
companion so let's head back to our
Oasis
each time we return we get to see how
much we've grown our garden and brought
new life to the environment let's plant
our seeds refill our flask and head back
out
we're going to show off a new area The
Canyons
when you first come here the canyon
floors are full of thick poisonous air
however we've managed to clear out most
of the poison already and uncover these
funky fungi
and there's all sorts of plants down
here that'll look great in our garden
this is great but how do we get back up
that is where the wind cloak comes in
the gardens looking better than ever and
we've even got some animal visitors
but we don't have to enjoy it alone
we can play online with up to three
friends to build our garden and explore
the world
we've come a long way but there's a lot
more to find out there in the world of
wildmender
oh
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
although I am not a fan of ambrosia
salad at all the most disgusting thing
on earth mythrect is putting my faith
back into the nectar of the Gods looks
so cool KOA frogen and all of the games
in that segment look so handcrafted it
makes me excited to check out the future
of those games before we move forward we
want to give a shout out to our sponsors
and developer partners for supporting
the Showcase and bust out a key drop
here is your chance to grab some keys
check it out take a snapshot going going
gone if you missed out on that one we'll
have more coming soon up next we are
going to unpack our Sabers Shields and
guns and get into some new titles in the
RPG and strategy category
hey I'm Craig Ritchie game director on
broken roads and from all of us at drop
bear bites we're really excited to give
you a look at what the team's been up to
lately
now the game has come such a long way in
terms of the art quality since we first
showed it off in 2019 from character
redesigns to Caucasians and obviously
all of the new interiors that the team
have been working so hard on we're just
incredibly proud of the way it's looking
we really want this to be one of the
most beautiful RPGs you've ever
experienced
the writing is also very close to
complete and there are hundreds of
moments throughout the game where you'll
be able to see the world or the people
in it that you've met early on your
journey react to the choices that you've
made small moments that you may have
thought to an insignificant Choice can
can really come back in a big way later
on so we're super excited to see how
players you know what they pick up and
what they notice and also the different
experiences that different players have
based on their earlier choices
so expect broken roads to take about 25
hours to complete but with four origin
stories uh four moral quadrants and 36
000 possible places on the moral campus
one of the things we're really excited
to see is the many ways that the game
can be played and replayed based on
whatever world view you want your
character to have and the way the moral
compass slowly shifts with every moral
decision we make this is a new system we
you know it's experimental it's
something we're really really Keen to
get into players hands the reception to
it has been really great so far and yeah
we've we've got some really really cool
moments in store and very keen to see
you know how players will vary from you
know who they are in real life versus
the character that they want to role
play with the scenarios that we've set
up
now as part of the move from you know 2D
tile based art to a fully 3D world that
we've got now we've also updated the
combat moving it from the grid-based
format it was when we first showed off
the game in 2019 and 2020 to fully
free-form movement so along with that
there's a full UI overhaul we've got out
of the boxer portal console controls
mask and keyboard and yeah some really
new fun enhancements to the AI as well
so it'll be up very keen to see what
players do with that
just like the original Fallout and more
recently disco Elysium there's ways to
talk puzzle you know explore your way
through non-violently if you do want to
try one of the many pacifist paths
through the game
we've also taken multiple trips to
Western Australia added in many Real
World locations trying to keep
everything authentic we've taken
thousands of reference photographs on
our trips there and the art team have
done an absolutely fantastic job of
bringing these you know well-known towns
major landmarks and even some
lesser-known spots that you'll encounter
along the way you uncover as you go
we're really looking forward to finally
getting the game into players hands
later on this year but until then we've
got a lot more lined up to show you in
the coming months so please follow us in
socials check out our YouTube and of
course wishlist broken roads on Steam
thank you
[Music]
Shadow Gambit the cursed crew is a
stealth strategy game that's set in the
Lost Caribbean which is an alternate
history version of the Caribbean we know
and it's set during the Golden Age of
piracy and your goals to assemble a crew
of cursed pirates with cool magical
abilities to find the legendary treasure
of Captain Mordecai
the vision for shadow Gambit was to
really push the genre we want to give
the players as much Freedom as possible
this time and for the first time we
added magic which opens a whole new
world of opportunities
so we have these islands that you can
explore where you can play the way you
want to play and we have the characters
with awesome abilities and you can
combine them as well the way you want to
so every Mission becomes kind of unique
depending on what you choose and that's
the strength of the game and the sort of
core we're aiming for
Freedom starts with a pirate ship as it
should in a pirate game her name is the
red Mali and she's basically one of the
main characters in the game as well so
you can talk to your ship and you can
use the red Mali to sail to different
islands in the Lost Caribbean and have
missions there
we moved from a linear Mission order a
linear story to an open structure and
it's up to you which island you want to
visit first which Mission you want to
tackle every island is like a small
sandbox so you choose like oh the beach
looks very nice to me I've never been
there I want to enter there and you go
on your mission you complete your
objective so overall it's really up to
you how you explore each island
you can also choose the crew you want to
bring on that mission and see I want to
maybe tackle it this way so I'll bring
these guys and gals with me or someone
else might have a very different idea
and the mission plays very differently
on whatever you choose
this time you Cruise enhanced by Soul
magic which makes them more powerful so
you can tackle some situations heads on
and if something goes wrong you're
already dead and curse you can revive
your currents
since we finally have a world filled
with magic we can give these characters
magical abilities we're not constrained
by well boring things like realism
anymore so we can give these characters
extremely crazy and fun skills that we
couldn't before and that's something I'm
very excited about
in our first Gameplay trailer we already
showed you three of the characters and
now we're gonna unveil the fourth one
his name is Toya and he's an undead
ninja pirate basically which is pretty
awesome in itself and he has the ability
to teleport around long distance so that
makes him very strong you can use that
to attack and just stab a guard teleport
onto them or you can use it to escape
maybe you ran into some place cost some
Mayhem and you just teleport back out
there so the Inquisition can't get you
so if you master him you can nearly be
in two places at once and the real fun
then comes from combining your different
team members and experimenters their
skills and find new synergies we're very
excited to show you more of Shadow
Gambit the cursed crew in the future so
please wish list the game on any
platform of your choice thanks
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
yeah hey so I guess I should tell you a
bit about myself the name's Woody and I
got kicked out of my last school for
fighting no big deal really other than
my mom freaking out and threatening to
kick my butt if the same thing happened
at the school all I'm trying to say is
cool is tough but you gotta be tougher
you know parents just don't get it
anyway I've met some pretty cool people
here
[Music]
[Applause]
but there are a couple of jerks who are
just asking for it and before you bring
up my mom I was only defending myself
okay
I just want to get through this here in
one piece without someone calling me a
troublemaker
[Music]
foreign
in our last segment we slowed things
down and had some great RPG and strategy
games we're going to shift gears and get
into some games all about that action we
have some quality titles that range from
roguelike side scrollers to fast-paced
and methodical Shooters and everything
in between
let's take a look
[Music]
roguelike hyperkinetic neon drenched
action platformer that will test your
skills to their limits you play as the
Fearless titular character Elsie an
Android on a mission to save her world
from the disasters that have plagued it
to do so you'll have to travel through
multiple wild and unpredictable
locations each filled with countless
enemy robotic hordes but fear not Elsie
comes equipped with a powerful arsenal
of weapons and abilities to help her
take on any Challenge from the trusty
sidearm to Elemental Cannons of
Destruction there's a weapon for every
situation with a huge list of items and
augments to customize each run you can
tailor your playstyle to suit your
preferences as you progress through each
biome you'll encounter powerful bosses
that stand in your way these epic
battles will test your skills and
strategies to their limits culminating
in a final showdown with each biomes
Guardian boss with a stunning neon
drenched art style and a pumping
soundtrack Elsie is a game that will you
on the edge of your seat so get ready to
take on the challenge of this thrilling
action-packed game and save your world
from certain destruction in LC players
start their Adventure at the saper Wharf
a peaceful Bastion where the survivors
of the attack on Dr Gray's City have
taken refuge and will serve as the
game's main Hub here the player can take
the lighthouse teleporter to the very
first level the eclipse skyport the
eclipse skyport is our aerial biome
which houses our first Guardian Celestia
accompanying Celestia is an army of
different enemies and Elsie will
encounter enemies such as the valkyrie
seraphim and wind Elemental will make
Elsie's path a bit more difficult upon
defeating the boss at the end of the
skyport the player then must choose from
one of three teleporters that will take
them to the next bio each individual run
will go over three of the five bios our
team has put a lot of emphasis on the
game's art style and level design the
environments are full of detail and the
encounters are challenged changing but
very rewarding the forge Masters caldero
located in the volcanic Grotto is home
to Ash the forge Master Ash is a master
of creation and destruction she has the
ability to shape metal and rocks and has
created some fiery enemies that Elsie
must contend with on her journey the
Jardin is the home of our queen of
thorns Rosalind as our nature biome it's
home to some unique enemies that will
try to slow down Elsie as she tries to
fight through the fungus that has taken
over this Kingdom each biome will have
some small Easter eggs of people and
games that have influenced us all let us
know if you found any yet we've made
sure that each biome has its own unique
look style and feel offering a new
atmosphere with every run new bosses to
defeat and one memorable Guardian fight
to cap off the biome these are only some
of the worlds and bosses that await
Elsie our team has been working
tirelessly to ensure that Elsie offers a
dynamic gameplay experience with every
run players will level up and evolve
their by obtaining different items
weapons and augments found throughout
all of these environments these items
will drastically change how a player
will experience the game making every
playthrough a unique Adventure we are so
excited to be working on LC and we
cannot wait to share it with the world
stay tuned for more updates on our
developmental journey and we can't wait
for you to experience the game for
yourself thank you for your support and
we'll see you at the Wharf
foreign
[Music]
hello everyone it is an honor to be able
to introduce our project through the mix
showcase
the Devil Within satgot begins in a
small country in the East one day a
black wedge suddenly appeared in the sky
and the red oil that flowed infinitely
from it was a substance that could
replace all energy and surprisingly
cured all diseases it even possessed the
efficacy of governance thanks to this
this small country achieved great
prosperity for a while the abundance did
last suddenly news of demons appeared
and more than half of the people in the
country became abnormal in an instant in
the end people realized that the black
wedge was the cause of all the problems
and led General Hong sang and Royal
Guard Kim lip to set out together to
destroy the heart of the wedge
the game is a side-scrolling action game
with an emphasis on combat using
swordsmanship
in the early stages of the game it
starts with gameplay that involves using
simple slashing attacks dodging and
guarding to anticipate the timing and
exploit the weaknesses of the enemy
later on as Kim lip grows he learns
various and flashy techniques we
designed and implemented a lot of system
devices in the game because we never
wanted to create a spectacle where the
player is easily defeated by mashing
buttons
we are putting our heart and soul into
providing you with interesting
experiences in various aspects today we
would like to introduce you to the boss
battles that we pursue
this boss battle scene was revealed
through the Tokyo game show 2022. it's a
battle with the first main boss Lee
Chung the mercenary Captain our focus in
implementing this battle was to design
it to feel like a fighting game we put a
lot of effort into creating scenes where
similarly balanced Fighters engage in
offense and defense digging deep for
openings and unleashing combination
attacks
and this scene is a battle with a giant
boss mother Gaia which was created
during the initial prototype phase since
it is a boss battle that was developed
very early on we are currently reworking
it for a more exciting combat experience
our goal is to make all aspects of the
boss room part of the game's variables
and create a variety of tense situations
we are also excited to see if we can
describe some unconventional tactics
after the rework
this game and the hero Kim Lipps story
are still shrouded in many secrets
please pay attention to the Epic story
of Kim lips resistance against the
malevolent ten evils who are leading the
world to destruction and we will do our
best to develop the game to make this
journey an interesting one for you we
ask for your continued support and
interest thank you
hello my name is Craig Hauser I am a
level designer at angry mob games we're
working on a brand new action roguelite
called Trinity Fusion a Sci-Fi side
scroller with a big emphasis on smooth
satisfying combat in Trinity Fusion
you'll play as Maya a woman psychically
connected with her three parallel selves
across the Multiverse their worlds are
falling apart and you and your
counterparts are the key element in a
plan to reconnect them fusing each of
their worlds back together into one
stable timeline
the worlds of Trinity Fusion are in a
constant state of flux each time you
step out into the Multiverse levels are
procedurally generated out of hundreds
of handcrafted rooms Arenas and
challenges
as you reclaim key areas in each
Universe you'll unlock access to new
starting points allowing you to hop
between universes to bypass certain
areas giving you a bit of extra freedom
to choose your path through each run
whenever you come back from the
Multiverse you'll be returning to the
Citadel hidden away in a pocket
Dimension it's complicated but this is
where a small cabal of Engineers are
working to help you in your mission
among them is sendara Maya's partner who
maintains the machines that link Maya to
her counter selves by bringing sendara
materials she can augment the link
between Maya and her other selves
unlocking new permanent upgrades that
you can equip before you head out again
Trinity Fusion is all about great
feeling combat it's a dance of slashes
and Dodges punctuated with satisfying
special moves
you'll strike enemies with your melee
weapon to build up power Dodge their
attacks when you see their eyes Flash
and then blow them away with powerful
energy weapons like rocket launchers or
heavy battle hammers
each of your alternate selves have their
own set of unique abilities weapons and
traversal tools to help them fight
through their worlds
altara has a drone equipped with a
short-range teleporter allowing her to
reach distant areas and bypass foes it's
also handy for collecting items or
activating a distance switch
naira has an active camel module
allowing her a brief moment of
invisibility to quickly disengage from a
fight or slip past an enemy undetected
Kara's Cannonball ability is great for
both starting a fight or ending it or
just crossing small gaps
these abilities don't cost energy
operating on a cooldown Instead try
mixing them into your gameplay to give
yourself more of an edge in combat
we're really excited to share Trinity
fusion with you all we can't wait to see
what you think of the game when you
finally get your hands on it later this
year in the meantime wishlist and follow
us on Steam to stay up to date with our
progress and we'll see you out there in
the Multiverse
[Music]
oh
space station owned by Shad Enterprise
are suffering merciless attacks from the
extremist organizations
they pose us with a greater challenge by
infiltrating Frontier missions in
cooperation with Traders manipulation
and spreading hostility among Frontiers
leading them to their demise
[Music]
[Applause]
the new generation of energy source that
will brighten the path to a prosperous
future for Humanity your mission as a
loyal space Frontier is to destroy all
energy cubes in the mission area failure
is not an option
destroyed in time it will collapse onto
itself and results in a massive
explosion
you must at all costs destroy all energy
cubes and protect the Keystone from
falling into the hands of the tree
[Music]
can we preserve Humanity's Soul hope of
survival new Columbia
[Applause]
and maybe you'll get some monetary
compensation and a certificate and maybe
even a shiny badge I don't know
let's just go to the frontier Training
Center already
thank you
foreign
[Music]
CEO of perfect random and this is our
game sulfur
sulfur is based on pretty much
everything we like
there's a lot of Gore a lot of guns and
it's pretty difficult this is the first
time we show a little bit more of the
game you play as a priest your
congregation was put into flames and
your church was burned down you chase
the antagonist down to this cave do you
start exploring and that's what we see
now
here are designers trying to fight off
some dogs and they actually died there
and there's a lot of that dying and if
you die you lose all their stuff but
that's part of the difficulty and part
of the appeal and when you actually
clear an area you feel a bit of
achievement
you can strategize and use your grenades
to clear out multiple enemies
here's the human chanting his weapon
with the plague scroll this will add
poison damage to his bullets so he can
strategically put dots on enemies and
kind of kite them out
we tried to create tactile creative
Weaponry where you can combine things
how you want them and be creative
you can add different Scopes silencers
Red Dot sights and other fun stuff
so next to the poison and Chapman he
added to his gun he also added a fire
enchantment to his shotgun
here's a revolver type gun with the
silencer and a scope
and that's a goblin civilian who will
alert the others unless you kill him
pretty fast after you
you heard him
and you probably will because you're a
sadistic megalomaniac just be careful
not to put yourself on fire
now you gotta eat that chocolate
eat the taco eat the dumpling
move on
Good Times
making the enemies die in cool ways is
one of the core design tours of the game
and very important to us it's also
important to us that you find new stuff
whenever you repeat the run and you play
again and you have new things to
discover new things to explore and the
levels will change as you go
another way we make the environments
feel varied and different is that we
work with multiple artists who will
compose music for the different areas of
the game which will make them have their
own kind of feel their own kind of voice
and unique type of fire history for
every area
we have so many Inspirations for this
game and we're not really hiding any of
them we just want to make the game that
we ourselves want to play and we think
that you want to do that too
wishlist our game on Steam follow us on
Twitter and other places we post and
yeah follow our progress
thank you
[Music]
prepare thyself
the universe away
foreign
thank you
greetings everyone I'm simota composer
sound designer and writer at still
running I'm thrilled to present to you
today an exclusive sneak peek of our
upcoming action RPG morbid the Lords of
Aya morbid the Lords of Aya is the
second installment in The Morbid game
series following its isometric pixel art
predecessor morbid the seven acolytes in
order to take the series to the next
level we took the daunting leap of
bringing the world of morbid to the
third dimension and are now eager to
show you what we've been working on in
morbid the Lords of Ayah duty calls this
driver once more the devious deities
known as the gahars have risen Anew in
the ancient land of Aya through the
fresh brood of dreadful acolytes you a
fierce Warrior Bound by Duty must
reverse the accursed land and slay the
Fallen Lords of the five factions to rid
the gahas of their flesh many of the key
features from the first morbid game will
make their return in morbid the Lords of
Aya only this time with even more depth
and diversity such features include our
perk-based player upgrade system a
rune-based weapon upgrade system as well
as the ever so punishing Insanity system
essentially we took what was great about
morbid and made it better still
the combat mechanics in morbid the Lords
of Ayah have been given a lot of love
both the striver and her enemies have
been equipped with extensive and highly
responsive move sets in order to produce
versatile combat encounters with several
exciting ways of resolving them and to
amp up the variables even further the
striver has over 10 different weapon
classes with unique wielding stars and
combos to utilize in battle as well as a
one-of-a-kind firearm the spectral
blaster in addition to these revamped
core features morbid the Lords of Aya
will also offer a variety of memorable
characters quests looting New Game Plus
modes and of course a law filled world
of abysmal beings and gorgalore we are
super excited to bring Moby to the Lords
of Aya to consoles and PC later this
year stay tuned wishlist us and follow
us on social media to be among the first
to know the release date of morbid the
Lord survive thank you so much for your
time enjoy the rest of the show
magrathius bless you striver
hello we are the developers of leaf
alone ordering the apocalypse and we
want to tell you something about the
game
people honor order of the Apocalypse is
an action roguelike adventure
the game is setting a featuring with the
apocalypse have taken place
the game is based on this comic book
style we really wanted the player to
feel that they are reading a comic book
that they are playing a comic book so
everything in the game is hand drawn
to play as an agent from an organization
in charge of killing and destroying all
the paranormal activities in the world
in this game you you use a
all sort of weapons and abilities to
kill enemies
the idea is to have two different webs
at the same time and if the enemies have
big heavy enemy to use a big heavy
weapon
as you are surrounded by enemies you
should use a more agile weapon for
assembly dual Qatar because if you are
using the wrong weapon you most likely
are going to die
so while playing this game you get to
learn more about the universe which is a
very wide and bust on Dark Universe
you will unveil a story a dark story to
be told to you by comic books and by
panels and conversations and you unveil
a different Universe in which the dark
and the horror is present and you are
the only one capable of saving the world
the man works the man fails
over and over discarding that which he
creates
consumed by disgust by despair
his own hideous uselessness and in the
lightless catacombs beneath she Whispers
the heart is yours for the taking the
voice insists
they soothe one another
they talk in the dark
they never stop
a conference of lonely monsters
in his preoccupation the man has led the
other ones slip from his mind
in that shadowed Hall a man rises to his
feet
surrounded by strange machines
the instruments of his numerous failures
and he laughs
long and bitter
and sad
all of those games are looking super
slick sulfur and Luna Abyss I cannot
wait for those the Devil Within looks
super dope can't wait over the years we
have showcased hundreds of devs who are
up to the challenge of becoming creative
hustlers in the game industry with that
being said we want to honor the great
sacrifice and energy it takes to release
a game with some updates and new reveals
from mixed alumni whose games are on the
precipice of release
hi I'm Mark Cook CEO of shiny shoe as a
studio we're best known for our
roguelike deck building card game
Monster train and now we're working on a
new roguelike inkbound and I'd like to
show you how it plays let's go
upon entering the game you start out in
a magical Library called the athenium
that contains all stories ever written
it acts as a central MMO style Hub where
you can take on quests from NPCs change
character classes chat with other
players and party up with them
when it's time to start a run players
select from unranked or ranked modes and
then teleport into the sea of ink as a
roguelike we want players to experience
a high density of interesting decisions
and the payoff of going from weakling to
God over the course of the Strategic
roguelike run
you'll make a variety of decisions
throughout a run to upgrade ability
bindings draft Vestige items and choose
what types of risks and rewards you want
to take on after choosing initial
upgrades you must choose a book to visit
from the atheniums library today I will
choose the Proving Grounds
a threatening Force called the unraveled
is seeking to destroy the books of the
Atheneum throughout each book we'll
encounter the unraveled and it's our job
to defeat them and save the stories
inkbound may look like an action RPG
because you can move freely but it's not
combat is turn-based abilities are aimed
during the player turn like MOBA skill
shots we've taken care to make the game
really fluid there's no grid players can
act quickly and in multiplayer players
can act in any order
each combat ends in rewards and more
decisions choosing wisely is required to
survive live long enough and you'll face
a villain the final boss of the Run win
or lose we update your progress in a
detailed logbook tracking a variety of
objectives with many hours of
challenging gameplay required to
complete them all
I hope you like this small snippet of
inkbound gameplay we're launching in the
second quarter of 2023 on Steam in Early
Access hope to see you in the athenium
[Music]
hi everybody my name is tomasala I am
the Creator and solo death of bulwark
Falconer Chronicles an upcoming open
World sandbox Builder that's getting a
demo as well and I'm here to show it off
to you so let's just Dive In
um everything you see on the screen
right now as I'm flying through my
settlement I built earlier in the game
the harbors the big fortified Center
even the bits of Industry which are down
here in the corner the dockyards and the
places people live it's all built in the
game using procedural systems of the
game I can skip down to the ground mode
and let's do some building
um as you can see I can just select the
nearest building it's all sort of a
nodal system and from any Tower a build
line will extend and I can click
literally anywhere and a tower will be
built and it will be connected I can
even try to get up here because it's 3D
and we can go all the way up the
mountain we can connect it back to
existing buildings and if we play good
enough attention we'll see people move
in there's little there's one person
already set up their house and as we
keep building uh basically what you
build is filled in by population of your
settlement
you can build out these things called
Foundation you can also upgrade your
Towers in this case to Stone and build
stone stone walkways and we can even
build defensive works that come with
these giant fortified bastion-like
structures
which I can build I'll build sort of
messily attach some stuff we could go up
a number of floors uh add some stuff
there as well
um and when you finish one of these
towers they can become command towers
and that means you can assign one of the
commanders which you find in the open
world or you know from a friendly
faction to your Tower and what will
happen is if I go back to Flying round
mode they will transform that Tower into
their headquarters and spawn in this
case giant dragons uh to support you on
your explorations
and Defend Your settlement as well and
when we enter the open world we'll now
have this little how do you call it um
a task force Defending Your surveyor
let's see if there's anything on the map
interesting there is something there
just behind us
so let me fly past my settlement into
the world and you can see these question
marks pop up that's actually probably a
captain wanting to sell their services
uh and he's docked at our little city
others but a question mark can also be a
hostile encounter and uh there's a
fiction and a resource system also I
play there in this case it's it's a
small pirate Outpost that's set up
really close to our settlement I don't
know if I approve of that and they
actually want to join me which I'm not
in favor for their privates uh let's see
what happens when my new task force of
giant Weavers
gets to work and I torch any incoming
fire with my little surveyor uh which
I'm not controlling with the mouse also
trying to track
uh what's happening so while the these
guys hopefully finish up the Pirates uh
or myself that is an introduction to
bulwark a demo is available now you can
try it out yourself it's open
development so the demo will expand and
all your feedback just helps to make the
game better so thanks and uh bullmark
[Music]
have a nice test is a 2d ancient Rogue
light where you play as CEO of death
Incorporated dress himself
foreign
is responsible for processing All Souls
entering the afterlife but even death
can't escape the piles of dreaded
paperwork
so he created the Sorrows to help with
his reaping but instead they've gone out
of control making even more work instead
of left
as the CEO of Jessie you need to whip
those tunnels into shape and get them to
Fuller Waters so you can get back on
with your vacation fans
[Music]
manage your way through the seven
Departments of the afterlife and set the
company on tracks and no need to fear
the company has plans to expand with new
departments
the only thing you can count on at
jetting is death itself but it won't be
a grind
Department floors have a variety of
different options to choose from and are
uniquely arranged to keep every attempt
new and intrigued I find the perfect
tool to put those solos back in their
place
and for every failure it is a shiny
silver light use your earned inputs from
each attempt to unlock
so you can get back to packing and
siding away for now
once you've changed failure to complete
success there are 50
50 modes and
printed yourself with and become the
ultimate CEO
still haven't gotten the hang of it
there's even a mode to make things a
little easier for you to get your
footing
running Jazz Incorporated is a
challenging Endeavor but luckily you
have a plethora of useful features give
yourself helpful curses with downsides
happening only some of the time
heads down to the forge and Empower your
weapons or even accept some special
contracts before heading out
along with a range of other options the
company has the utmost confidence in you
to get the job done
so join your cloak grab your scythe and
get ready to
have a nice day
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
you know there's a new game called Kung
Fury Street rage and starring me it's
the ultimate edition hello there games
developed on a platform near you
Kung Fury Street rage brand new Ultimate
Fighting coming your way play as
Hasselhoff the world's most iconic
lifeguard steps in with his singing
prowess and oh that's a nice chest here
sir
more actually more awesome enjoy the
breathtaking multiplayer as player 2
joins the fight yeah two because
Teamwork Makes the Dream Work
choose your stage punch Nazis in the
sewers on the beach in the Viking age
hell punch Nazis everywhere all the time
Kung Fury Street rage
soon available on a platform near you
[Music]
love to all of the developers who have
been grinding on their games we are
honored to let you know that Kung Fury
the physical version of the games is out
now for pre-order on LRG
limitedrungames.com as we speak so go
ahead and cop that all the games are
looking so good make sure to wish list
them and follow them on their socials
support them however you can also
subscribe to our twitch and YouTube
channels for more content and go to
Media Indie exchange.com to check out
all the links and and all the game Pages
for our final segment we're going to
look into some of the most interesting
and Innovative games that have a
different dimensionality of fun
experiences that just straight up hit
different let's take a look at some up
and coming creative games with
personality that are a breath of fresh
air
welcome may I introduce you to Henry
Henry is not just anyone if they're
anything there well everything Henry can
transform into everything in their reach
yes everything and that's how they
manage their daily life it's how they
make their bed every morning
[Music]
or how they enjoy a beautiful bubble
bath
it's how they make their morning coffee
how they relax and calm down
or how do you care for what they love
finding joy in the simplest things
get to know Henry's life story from
their Carefree days as a baby to their
first responsibilities as a working
adult until their calmer a more
laid-back senior years double the Henry
double the fun
play Henry's not so ordinary everyday
life in Cold Road
Henry everyday life with a Twist
hi I'm Ed from secret mode we want to
welcome you to the wholesome world of
laudelnut the debut title from Moon
Lagoon lottlenaut is a cozy aquatic
Survival game where you're a space
janitor who's sent to clean up a
polluted ocean planet abandoned by a
mega Corporation you begin your model
naught Adventure near Ripple Reef a
shallow coral reef area where you can
get to grips with the basics of cleaning
up picking up cans bottles and six-pack
rings and using your bubble gun to zap
the toxic sludge off surfaces you also
have a handy scanner to pinpoint hard to
find pollutants cleaning an area causes
plant life to flourish the team have
spent a lot of time tweaking the zapping
mechanic to make it feel as satisfying
as possible think of it as a power wash
swimulator every biome you visit is more
heavily polluted than the last slots and
flats our second area is a crater popped
environment and littered with shipwrecks
and cargo crates restoring this area
requires more effort for example you
can't just zap these crates instead
you'll have to pry metal latches off
their Corners to crack them open luckily
you can put all your collected trash to
good use by turning them into material
bits to upgrade your bubble gun better
yet you'll build new cleaning Tech such
as purifier bombs trash vacuum drones
and ride-on goop scrubbers you can also
expand your oxygen levels to extend your
range without needing to race back to
base to top up your supply or you can
build and place new oxygen rings out in
the world itself Pro tip cleaning
tubular sponges also releases air
bubbles to gulp down and now for the
stars of the game the lottels these
stilotal-like aliens are the blood of
lottle Nord while it's technically your
job to clean these oceans you'll want to
do it for your new friends when you meet
your first model it's covered in muck
and our bubble gun is too harmful to use
on it directly but what if we try that's
better models are very friendly and love
to follow you you can feed them pet them
and even communicate with them during
development the team looked at amazing
games such as subnautica and abzu but
the biggest Inspirations of all are
Sonic Adventure 2's ciao Garden mode and
Tamagotchi the team really wanted to
capture the joys of hatching and raising
cute alien friends lottels even evolve
depending on what you feed them and we
hope you'll love them as much as we do
little naught is coming to PC later in
2023 but you needn't wait that long
wishlist the game on Steam and you can
dive right into our playable demo
restore Ripple Reef to its former glory
and befriend your very first lottle
today
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
no no no no no
no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no
thank you
hi I'm preethi and this is my game
gordlets gordlets is a cozy city
building sandbox Place buildings in
scenery and then watch visiting gordlets
arrive and interact with the world
no objectives no score is just building
you can make your Island as large or as
small as you want with the variety of
buildings and plants and other objects
to choose from
the cordless will start fishing on docks
roasting marshmallows by the fire and
interacting with the world you've
created
you can choose whether it's day or night
and you can control the weather
[Music]
even enter buildings and turn them into
cafes libraries houses and more
there aren't any stressful objectives or
time limits and nothing to level up or
keep track of it's just about building a
rich world and watching it come to life
cordless is the perfect game to relax
and unwind with with no objectives to
worry about just build create and watch
as your world flourishes
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Manor
[Music]
stately home in 19th century England
you play as Arabella green a retired
botanist exploring her house and Gardens
filled with research
to figure out the ideal habitat of
Forgotten Flora
hildu herbarium by growing each plant
and discovering the mysterious qualities
that they hold
botany Manor is an exploration puzzle
game where you play as a retired
botanist
foreign
Manor is set in the 19th century a time
of great scientific discovery
[Music]
explore a complete historical English
Manner and its grounds
[Music]
there are many rooms and Gardens to
discover all set inside a beautiful
countryside surrounding
[Music]
botany Manor is a relaxing and peaceful
environment
feel free to stop and smell the roses
[Music]
the puzzles you solve in botany Manor
come in the shape of growing plants
find seeds pot them and Carry Your
seedlings to their right environment
the plants you need to grow are fussy
and finding their ideal habitat will
sometimes require you to think outside
the box
there are many interactive items
scattered around the house that can help
you achieve this
we figure out each plant's habitat
they'll need to gather information by
inspecting Clues such as Botanical
posters newspapers letters paintings and
postcards literally anything you
encounter can be useful for your
research
foreign
by room you learn more about the life
and career of Arabella and the
challenges that she faced as a woman
navigating her scientific career
[Music]
you can wish list botany Manor now on
Steam
and to stay up to date on the latest
news you can follow botany Manor on
Twitter and tick tock
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
hats off to all the teams that put so
much energy into making something
different and exciting Henry half head
looks like my jam and I cannot help but
seeing the fifth element in Crazy Taxi
in the Yellow Taxi goes room so cool
well that's it guys so many dope games
awesome devs and experiences to look
forward to I think you should just throw
money at the screen right now because
those games look so delectable time for
a key drop our final one take out your
phones and take a snapshot of the QR
code on the screen check it out grab
some keys yes and that's it be sure to
check out the mix event page on Steam
where you can learn more about all of
the up and coming games on this show
play some of their demos wish list the
games and you will be notified when they
are available get them on all the other
platforms too support them however you
can we want to give a shout out to our
sponsors for helping to make this thing
happen PlayStation raw Fury and Wilson
suncini and freedom goblins limited run
neon Doctrine New Blood super Thunder
full tiny build white Thorn games wire
Productions and Razer shout out to our
broadcasting partners for supporting
this showcase and the developers on the
stream twitch IGN Gamespot steam
everybody who co-stream you guys are so
dope salute to the developers who are
participating they have all contributed
their game's Blood Sweat and Tears to
make this thing possible as well we want
to thank the mix team
without you guys it wouldn't make this
happen without us we wouldn't make this
happen Abe Travis Joel Mary Knapp Heidi
Matt Timmy all the developers as well
you guys and gals are awesome for tuning
in
big shout out to you and thanks for
joining us make sure to subscribe to our
twitch and YouTube channels follow us on
Twitter at Indie exchange everywhere
else at midi any exchange media Indie
Exchange
up next is another black voice in gaming
presented by Destiny and Khalif again my
name is Justin Woodward co-founder of
the mix bvig bgdf we'll talk to you soon
peace
[Music]
what is up my good people if you missed
it we finished celebrating Black History
Month with a special bvig showcase not
as it may be we couldn't leave you
hanging in March let's just be real bvig
is celebrating black achievements in the
game industry year around it was created
in June of 2020 during the protests and
demonstrations that United us worldwide
black voices and gaming has gone from a
showcase to a non-profit organization
that helps accelerate the growth of
professional game developers you might
be wondering how
well our mission is to facilitate a
space where game Studio entrepreneurs
can access funding meet Publishers and
connect with mentors to help them
succeed as always it's great to be back
here co-hosting black voices and gaming
my name is Destiny and I've literally
always got something going on but being
part of black voices and gaming is
always something that I feel extremely
proud of you can also catch me at level
one gaming a minority-owned organization
that focuses on gaming news
entertainment and all things be culture
but before we jump into today's amazing
guest I'm gonna let my co-host introduce
himself
what's good everybody hey Dez thank you
so much for having me everybody at home
my name is cod Leaf Adams I own and run
the award-winning spawn on Me podcast
the premier podcast Spotlight with
people of color in the video game
industry alongside that I also run the
spawnies which is a gaming award show
that's here to give love to
underrepresented devs within the space
last but not least I'm also a debit
fireworks Studios and super excited to
be here rocking with all of you here and
Dez it is so cool to be with you and all
the folks at black boys and gaming and
all the fam out there watching
yeah I'm excited I'm I'm so happy to see
you like we keep going in circles where
we see each other but being here today
with you and like free recording and
having talks and everything is going to
be a blast but before we get in we
always have to thank our sponsors and I
think police is going to do great at
that so please
who are our sponsors and who are we
thinking I mean look we got to give love
to to the crew we got to give love to
the sponsors a massive shout out to
everyone who came and contributed first
we have to give love to our silver
sponsors we gotta talk about our folks
over at PlayStation uh massive fan of
everybody who's doing that work over on
the Sony brand I know I just got my psvr
to rocking it in virtual reality Dez how
are you doing how you rocking with the
PlayStation 2. oh my god listen I want
one and I just haven't gotten it yet
because I am I'm a little scared of a
virtual reality you know I might get in
there and not want to come back out
I have been there I have I've gotten
there for sure for sure for sure it has
been a rough time staying in virtual
reality because I don't want to leave
either but we got to talk about other
folks over at ID and Xbox as well
wonderful folks over on that team making
sure that the Indie space is getting the
love that it deserves what's up with you
and I need Xbox
well I just got my Xbox and like
um I'm loving it and also I'm looking
forward to getting a Black Panther
themed Xbox just if they have any in the
background that they uh have any spheres
on open I have a space on my shelf ready
for it you're ready to wakanda Forever
your way through all the games my way
forever through all the game you already
know it
last but
we also have for muscle responses we
have our friends from riot games uh I
have been digging into the new season of
valorent a ton getting my butt my butt
kicked all over the place but uh you've
been rocking some Riot games games
listen I tried out League of Legends
when I lived in South Korea and I will
just tell you the skill and um I don't
have it I don't have the skill for
League of Legends but I do enjoy all of
the things that they're putting out the
the trailers the female characters like
is dope so Riot you've got a fan of me
even though I'm terrible at your games
as a former writer I gotta give them the
big big daps uh for all the work that
they continue to do uh we also have our
other sponsors in raw Fury Razer and our
friends over at Wilson suncini uh giving
us some love as well and helping our
event go smoothly this year so super
excited about all of our sponsors and
yeah Dez what do we got next coming up
so we could not do the show without
thinking our Broad
well our broadcasters I don't know
what's wrong with me I can't talk this
morning but that's right let's not
forget them we have twitch gaming has
been there from the beginning IGN you
guys know what's up they actually did
like a round table with us last month to
talk about the importance of black
voices and gave me huge thank you to
them we have game jolt we also have Game
Spot and steam now listen speaking of
steam don't forget to check out the mix
event page on where you can learn more
about black voices and gaming titles buy
the available games and add them to your
wish list remember wish lists are super
super important so go do that it helps
the devs a lot not only that let's talk
about donations let's talk about merch
let's talk about socials because as I
said before black voices of gaming has
gone from a showcase to a non-profit so
listen we're gonna make it super easy
for you get your phone
pull up the screen where you can like
take a picture grab those QR codes and
please if you feel it in your heart
please donate no amount is too small and
we truly appreciate all of your help
also check out our merch guys we have
some dope T-shirts if you want to look
fly then you definitely have to get a
black voices and game a t-shirt
not only that if you want to keep up
with us remember to follow us on BVI
gaming at Twitter that's BVI gaming and
black voices and gaming on YouTube and
Instagram so now that we've said our
thank you we've shouted out our
appreciation it's time to get this show
rolling Khalif what do you have for us
tell us a little bit about our first
guest who's coming up next we have a
fantastic guest in zalavira Nelson Jr
we're going to be talking to him about
his game El Paso elsewhere super excited
about that game which you know brings a
lot of the fun uh uh Max Payne Vibes
that we've been waiting for uh and
hoping for uh in a game that we haven't
seen in a really long time so excited to
talk about zaliver and let's talk to him
right about now
98 of me is screaming in pain
or exultation
glad for an excuse to fall
I tell myself it was always going to be
a one-way trip
[Music]
that's what love is it's a strip between
who you were and
I come next
I need to know that you believe
so I can't do
ready
one two three
my name is James Savage
[Music]
here's to believing
oh my goodness what a great trailer for
El Paso elsewhere I am so excited for
this game really hyped forward what'd
you think about the trailer does I
thought it was Doe like I'm just as
it's ins and outs so
um who is that who's who's talking to us
today let's let's bring him on right now
zoliver Nelson Jr how are you zalavir
how's everything going
hey folks uh I'm doing great it is a
Thursday and the fact that I remember
it's a Thursday means that I'm doing
real good today
shout out to Thursday
video
Thursday give the folks at home a little
bit of info about you about what's going
on in your world and and talk to us a
little bit about El Paso elsewhere
yeah so uh I am a prolific Creator uh
with over 70 credits underneath my belt
uh I've done stuff from well I don't
need to interrupt you but that is dope
70.
over 70 in the past seven years
well I mean like the that's great like
pickups to you
it's an honor it's the industry as a
whole is not calculated to allow people
much space to uh grow personally let
alone Express their personal creativity
so the fact that I've had the
opportunity to do that growing up what
feels like light speed in this medium
and having the ability to contribute to
a lot of teams and now share that
knowledge every place I go uh while
picking up new tricks along the way has
been great so whether it's writing
production Biz Dev design uh and or
increasingly direction I've just been
working on a lot of stuff for a long
time I've worked in print and literature
and tabletop RPGs and comics and now I'm
honored to be presenting
um the first of uh the sort of next
phase of El Paso of strange scaffold
projects uh those Pro those projects
being El Paso elsewhere and sunshine
Shuffle we've got six games in
development those are the two that are
above water and our hope is to reveal
the rest of them before the end of the
year really show y'all what what we're
pulling together and the the level that
we're operating at when we're trying to
as the studio motto goes uh build games
better faster cheaper and healthier than
the industry assumes as possible
I mean you you and the team continue to
pump out some some fantastic and amazing
games you go from dogs running an
airport to trading organs in space and
now we get to El Paso elsewhere I gotta
know how the through line went through
from all of those conversations to what
we got a chance to see in the trailer
today
I think the big thing that I use to
direct the visions of these projects is
just
do I need to make this game before I die
and the answer
in this case was uh yeah vampire tragedy
uh
you know having a relationship with the
lord of the vampires is going to mess
you up in the process so you are coming
to El Paso Texas your hometown to stop
your ex from destroying the world which
means that in the process you might have
to kill the monster that you loved you
play as a rad black monster hunter
called James Savage in El Paso elsewhere
the game has the original hip-hop
soundtrack on which I'm a vocalist and
Lyricist uh yes yeah like we're making
games differently which means we can
afford to make games specifically games
that hit specific emotional ranges new
uh production processes wild things like
producing a full-on experimental horror
hip-hop album on top of building a Max
Payne spiritual successor for a genre
that has been pretty uh under touched uh
you know the throwback uh third person
shooter basically hasn't been made in
the past you know decade plus so uh
getting to explore that territory and do
that in style while also so uh having uh
running simultaneously things like
sunshine Shuffle where you're playing
cards and exchanging stories with cute
adorable animals you did a a horrible
crime 12 years ago and I'm telling you
how why they did it so they don't get
executed by the mafia
we're trying to show what is possible uh
in games uh and how you can try to build
different production uh strategies and
methodologies that mean that the people
who are building and collaborating on
these things with you don't get sure in
the process or at the very least get to
walk away no matter how the game does
and it changes genuinely the types of
games you can make I'm really excited to
be where we are right now
oh oh my God and listen like it just
sounds like you wear so many different
hats and I love that about the indie
game Space because it does kind of give
you that freedom to create what you want
to create whether it be because you have
to create a game before you die or just
because you want to put a game out there
that you think people would enjoy and I
think El Paso is like for me it's really
exciting not only because like I like
vampires and I like love stories but
also I get to go in and kick some butt
and I think that's incredible like I
didn't even know I needed this game
until I realized I needed this game you
know so
that's the goal we want to bring people
games that they don't know that they
need yet well you've done it you've
absolutely done it and I cannot wait to
play it but while we have you here
um you've also brought up another game
that we are going to be showcasing and
letting you guys see the trailer of and
then we're actually going to jump in and
play it a little bit so before we drop
that trailer can you tell us a little
bit more about sunshine Shuffle with
cute animals and the mafia and uh I'm
terrible at at gambling so like this
will be an experience for me
so uh Sunshine Shuffle uh began its
Genesis as a project in late 2020
obviously people had a lot of feelings
uh in 2020 and what we said was you know
what we just need like
just create a like a safe happy space in
a video game uh we haven't seen a poker
night at the inventory game in a while
there's only been two of those how hard
can it be to mix basically like a visual
novel and uh a poker game we could
probably replicate that Tech pretty
easily and do Animal Crossing meets
poker at night inventory with a bunch of
little friends and that had two problems
first of all despite even working with X
Telltale people on the game no one told
us that we were basically making the
immersive Sim of uh narrative games it
is probably the most nightmarish and
difficult
uh game production process strange
scaffolded experience so far not because
of uh work conditions but because
it's just a really really hard game to
make it has to work flawlessly all the
time uh and it's immediately obvious if
it doesn't work and if it does work you
don't get any credit for it because it
just looks like it's supposed to right
the second thing
is that it was boring it was boring
there was just nice people the table
around you and uh there was kind of a
light bulb click again talking about
games I need to make before I die and
ways to make them that I can be proud of
and that allow my me and my
collaborators to hopefully continue to
contribute to the industry for a long
time to come uh I was looking at this
game and saying I'm not having fun
trying to tell this story I don't know
what these characters are trying to say
and uh
it being my brain uh I jumped to okay
they robbed a bank 12 years ago uh they
thought they got away with it turns out
they took the mafia's money consequences
ensued and then you show up on their
doorstep so they're telling you how and
why they did it so that they don't get
executed by the mob uh also you get to
decorate the boat and then all these
things started to click in terms of the
game had teeth it had something to say
it had characters that you could uh
attach to and learn about and uncover
the depths of in a really
um really core way that made them feel
like a a cast in their own right and you
can still customize the boat now there's
a little poop every time you buy an item
or like a new deck of cards or some
chips uh so yeah even if you don't know
how to play poker you get to unravel a
fantastic story uh brought together by
some really talented people with an all
original ska soundtrack by scottoon
Network
we're making
has a huge uh every gamer making has
like kind of is taking these big
creative Swings with uh collaborators
both you've heard of and that you
haven't heard of at all and especially
taking big swings musically uh because
the games industry is full of cowards
who won't fill their soundtracks with
ska and uh I'm excited to break that
trend
ing fiber of my being oh my god
listen you had me at customizing my boat
yeah
I can decorate my boat like yes but I'm
sorry but if you want to like repossess
it that that's on you that's uh
it's my book and it's gonna look the way
I want it to look and they're just along
for the ride
well I know we have a world premiere and
we have some World premiere footage
we're gonna check out the game and and
get some some time on the sticks with it
right about now but also hearing you
talk about the game in that way uh it
reminds me of heat
uh in the movie Heat uh and I was just
thinking because of the animal component
in this game if you needed a subtitle
for Sunshine Shuffle you could say
Sunshine Shuffle uh dog in heat that
would be kind of an amazing under under
sponsored by spawn on me Khalif Adams
the dog in the heat conversation with
that we are gonna go to the trailer
here we go everybody hope you enjoy it
[Music]
perfect
all right guys we just saw the trailer
and now we're gonna jump into the game
I'm super excited because I want to
decorate I don't know if I'm gonna get
to decorate but I would like to decorate
so it's starting it depends on how good
you are at poker
I'm terrible
poker but Khalifa if he's getting it so
he can help
flush
three of a kind
two two pair
two pair and a dougie
what's two parents
oh that's dope I love that
okay so aha the new face well not new to
me but we'll cross that bridge with the
others when we get to it all right homie
I don't suppose you're in the mood to
reveal this deal you've concocted maybe
well I don't mind
if you did and polite I'll just throw
you overboard
yeah
it's a big ocean dang threats already
but if you won me over the rest of the
morning shift will take to you like up
take to you like pig to butter I like
the text animations on this too stuff
like that
the sooner we get started the sooner
they get their lives and the sooner I
can get to know you too mysterious
investigator I feel like he's hitting on
me do you guys feel like he's sitting
Equity I might be trying to get the
digits
speaking of who are you what do you want
to you know what my name is
hey guys continue
and I'm gonna be oh my God can I be a
cat okay we don't have a lot of time
I'ma be a rabbit
this is the big this is this is the big
moral choices that we don't often get in
games
I mean look it's so hard because I love
rabbits and I love frogs too and I
didn't see a cat so lovely if you're
sure about that we can get going I'm
sure I'm actually not sure this is
um this is one thing that we do to uh
alter the formula for uh poker at the
inventory is you can have dialogue
options now
I like that that gives you more
immersion okay without further Ado
welcome to the book that crime bought
and love keeps afloat oh yeah on me guys
okay welcome to the ultra sunshine
foreign okay
all right you hear the music Chinese
let's go I love skatoon too so talented
oh this is so good oh this is so nice
oh this is so good
I'm digging this so talk a little bit
about how it was to work with skatoon
uh scottun uh was is it Splatoon
I think you probably have it right
uh skatoon uh is is incredible uh Jer is
an incredible collaborator a musician uh
they we also worked with RJ Lake for the
music on this project for some of the
interstitial bits but uh scottun was an
incredible collaborator that kind of
there uh the DNA of good ska that you're
hearing right now uh ended up uh
premiering throughout the entire project
I'm really glad we got to work together
oh horns are hitting okay
all right it looks like they're playing
Texas Hold'em style text uh poker
guys Texas Hold'em let's just get
through like one round of this like if
we can um I have a five and a nine so
what do I do do I raise 20 do I call 10
do I fold the pot is 20. I wanna I wanna
hear zeliver's take on how to play this
hand this is gonna be good I like this
uh rays
race it's a short it's a short life uh
and if you go bankrupt they probably
aren't going to do anything uh bad at
like push you overboard or whatever so
just just raise
go big
go big or go home
good call hopefully yeah I'm hoping so
as always the one who like told me to do
it
okay
let's go animals have good Banta
um let's let's raise again oh my God I'm
scared
this pot is right next to uh 200.
yeah no we're probably gonna get thrown
overboard
Andy just folded so uh oh we're at 280
oh oh okay okay okay all right Dez is
bullying the pot right now we see it we
see it happening
oh this is a very bad hand for you to be
so invested in yes it is you might want
to pull it actually so talk a little bit
about the process aloe vera of you
learning how to play poker while kind of
going through the process of making the
game I kind of figured a five and a nine
would not be good you know what I'm
saying so um
okay I fold it oh things are heating up
yeah but I fold it
I feel like now yeah
that's a good play okay Billy
did you learn a lot about the process of
of playing poker while making the games
out of it
uh my team did uh it's been two and a
half years uh we're close to launch now
and I I don't know how to play
poker
I learned like seven separate times and
then I just forgot after a little bit
because there was different parts of the
projects and things like El Paso
elsewhere to like go over to and by the
time I came back from riding in neo-noir
uh love tragedy uh I forgot how to play
poker again
works that way
you guided me pretty well I'm still on
the boat and I didn't get thrown
overboard but guys we are coming to the
end because we are out of time please
please please uh go wishlist this game
go check it out because I can already
tell I'm gonna have a lot of fun and I'm
gonna learn a lot about gambling and I'm
gonna be a professional and not only
that
um me and how do you say his name the
leadius fidelius fidelius fidelius we're
obviously going to be a couple so
uh anyways right before we uh sign off
and I I start like giving my digits out
to this dog can you let the people know
where to find you if they want to find
out more about you your team and what
you've got going on
uh you can follow at strange scaffold on
Twitter on Instagram uh and also on
YouTube uh we've got El Paso elsewhere
uh a throwback slow motion shooter on
the way coming this fall and then
Sunshine Shuffle coming
in the near future uh to uh PC as well
as a mystery console El Paso elsewhere
will be on Xbox and PC uh you can wish
list them both now and uh the important
thing about sunshine Shuffle is that
even if it teaches you to gamble it does
not teach children to gamble I'm not
teaching children to gamble don't tell
steam or the FCC that I teach children
to gamble that isn't that that isn't why
that isn't what happened
you would never nothing like the cute
animals or anything that would actually
want to like you know get a child
creative and and want to play the game
that's not what you were aiming for
there at all
um and so steam we hope that you hear us
that's that's not what's going on here
but thank you so much for coming on and
sharing these games with us it was so
dope and uh I hope you guys are ready
because we have some more amazing guests
coming up soon
absolutely we have uh and before we get
to our next guest I gotta say zalavir
one of the best people on the planet
super super amazing one of the G and
Tick Tock games on the planet as well
but make sure you're checking out his
Tick Tock loved his vibe you only live
once
only live only live once
let's let's go over to our next guest we
have the man the miss the legend and
that is hip-hop gamer
press start
oh
hip-hop gamer Press Start
[Music]
yeah you know what time it is
how I got greater but those that don't
see it they stay stuck with their haters
hip-hop game but no stranger to
Greatness so drop that your gameplay
respond back Red Dot headshot
responsible your hard hat this is what
New York sounds like in a saw that
concrete core killer rap game horse bit
of rain data so you gotta aim for your
best out Ready for War we got the
painkillers feeling like Mike and again
this is New York City with a whole but
the gritty gotta feel me put the game on
[Music]
throw it up
this is
this is New York City or the city
this is New York City Old City
this is New York City York City we're
the home of the gritty gritty press
start for me
oh my God I know you guys were bump into
that video like it was incredible and
listen we have the one and only the
infamous hip-hop gamer with us today to
talk about his music his journey and all
things gaming what's up hip hop are you
in the house yeah you already know what
it is you know what I'm saying black
voices and gaming the goat of the game
is right here Hot 97 is going down love
you Destiny you already know what it is
let's get it popping let's talk that
talk you know what I'm saying and you
already know keep it real with me on hit
you know what I'm saying the realest is
right here so let's get that talking now
I mean let's go
oh my God I love the energy that you're
bringing to this like you get me
get me yeah that's the way it's Gotta Be
baby let's get it no you're right
positive positivity so listen we I I
wrote down a few key points and the
first thing that I want to ask you
super random super random but I heard
something about a wrestling belt and I
just can you tell me about the wrestling
belt and then we'll jump into like all
the other stuff but guys the wrestling
belt like it's been on my mind tell me
about the wrestling belt
got you so the wrestling belt it has
sentimental value because I was always
like my grandmother's Champion you know
what I'm saying and she's my champion
and my grandmother she's the one who
taught me how to play video games when I
was four years old so I've been playing
video games all my life and she taught
me about life through video games you
know what I'm saying so when I have the
belt it's not just about me being number
one or just being a champion for uh the
sake of selfish reasons you know what
I'm saying it's more about showing my
grandmother in the greatest light that I
can because she gave me what I give back
to y'all you know what I'm saying so
that's what the belt is all about it's
on the Belt it got Hip Hop Elements on
it in terms of DMX you know 50 Cent and
if you look at the game inside they got
Kratos Lara Croft which is my favorite
uh uh my grandmother's favorite
character was Laura Croft and then you
know you see HOT97 Logitech G AMD on the
Belt as well but the most important
thing on the belt is putting God first
so it says God first and as my
grandmother on it and my son on it so my
belt is a number one representation of
everything that makes me me and what I
give back to the industry and when I
give back to everybody in daily life
that encounters me period yo that's
what's up I didn't expect that story but
that was so touching and that was this
that was super sweet and the fact that
your grandmother is the one who got you
into gaming and Big Ups to Laura Croft
because she is she is the baddest baby
so I can see why she loves her yeah but
all right that was amazing that was
amazing thank you all right I'm sorry I
I took it off the rails we usually start
with tell us about who you are and what
you do and we will get into that now but
I needed to know about the belt and I'm
glad that you shared that story with us
but yeah appreciate it what else about
you
Well it Well like just to set the tone
ain't nothing like traditional like or
regular when it comes like to me you
know what I'm saying so you do what you
do baby you know what I'm saying you
have to worry about y'all stick to no
script you know what I'm saying like I
am the action be all the actions so
let's get that popping yo so you guys do
whatever you want you know what I'm
saying let's get it all right yo so
let's tell our audience a little bit
about hip-hop gamer who he is what he's
doing in the industry like we want to
know all of it give us the 4-1-1 got you
so the first thing is just with hip-hop
gamer you know my goal is to be number
one period like I don't call myself the
goat of the game for nothing and the
reason why I call myself to go with the
game because you can't be the goat
unless you take the hits period so the
thing is if you if you date back to 2008
and stuff like that that's when I first
got into the gaming industry from a
professional standpoint shout out to my
man Torrance Davis who had a website
back in the day called thebitbag.com he
uh discovered me and gave me opportunity
to go to E3 for the first time and when
I went to E3 yo in this 2008 yo so when
I went to E3
yo that was the biggest game changer
because I got a chance to understand the
other side of the gaming industry you
know what I'm saying see I only knew it
you know like how most of us knew it
just from a fan perspective just seeing
things now I get to understand how the
bottom lines work I get to understand
who's in control what happens why things
happen and I just kept studying and
learning studying and learning and
building up you know my brand by
understanding how the industry Works
fast forward to today 2023 you know I'm
the first game journalist to do a lot of
things and that's important to me not
just to be the best but like not just to
be the first but I want to be the best
at what I do in the first and if I'm not
the first I want to be the best at what
I did even though even if I was at first
so let's break it down so let's break it
down
um on the first game uh to bring gaming
and finance together on the biggest spot
ever that's the New York Stock Exchange
with fintech TV you know what I'm saying
so that was a barrier breaking moment
right there that's one two I'm the first
gamer to bring gaming to radio in the
form that I'm doing it now I want to
give a big shout out to my boy Godfrey
you know game attack radio because I
know at one point in time he was on CBS
Radio doing this thing too talking about
games so much props to him what I'm
saying is
um I'm actually the first ever
officially nationally syndicated Global
um voice in gaming on radio
um on all the biggest stations worldwide
because I'm partnered with aurn which is
the American Urban radio network so this
is the first that's the first time that
has ever happened I'm a character of
different video games I make songs for
the games and my I'm really my name you
know what I'm saying like hip-hop game
I'm really who I am I'm A hip-hop artist
I'm a gamer like I do this so I think at
the end of the day as long as everything
you do is authentic and I never work for
anybody in the gaming industry I always
been independent you know I'm saying
Dame dad status so I always been able to
do what I wanted to do help people and
continue to grow the industry so to me
just that much more of me
I wanted to set a tone that you could
still show Mad Love be positive and you
don't got you don't have to blow up by
being negative you don't have to blow up
by doing click bait to trigger people
you know what I'm saying you can be mad
cool make mad money and make an impact
positively and stuff like that I'm also
a partner with the board of education so
I actually have a program called
Playmakers where we utilize gaming to
teach financial literacy we utilize
gaming to develop character because the
slogan is character is your currency you
know what I'm saying so one of my main
things Destiny is everybody got their
own fingerprint you know what I'm saying
this world everybody has a one of one of
something I discovered what my one of
one was so at the end of the day
everything I do is exclusive to how I do
it so anything I attach myself to is
going to get the victory period so
that's how I operate that's a little bit
about me and some of the things that
I've been able to uh break barriers on
no I absolutely love that I love the
positivity and the energy that comes
into that because listen I feel like
growing coming up in our culture being
black like there's so many people
telling us no that it pushes us to be
like no we're not taking no for an
answer and if you don't want to listen
to me I'm gonna make my own thing and
that's exactly what you've been doing
and I think that's incredible because I
feel like with black voices in gaming it
is that platform and we're showing a lot
of developers a lot of create content
creators a lot of business people who
are out here making their own thing
without not saying that some people
don't help them but like really it's
them like the brand is them and I just
think listen I feel like when people
watch this
and they watch you and they watch Jay
and they watch all these developers like
it's really really inspiring
wow and I am inspired like legit like
there's so many things that I want to do
that sometimes I think we can get a
little overwhelmed with like man I don't
know if I can do this or you hear no so
many times you want to give up but you
are literally you and red and Jay and
all the developers we've had on even
Justin you guys are some of the most
amazing talented creative people that I
have had like the pleasure of working
with and I just I want to see you
succeed because I know that when you
succeed you are going to be lifting up
other people to help them succeed and I
think that's what's incredible because
it's not as selfish I want to be number
one it's a I want to be a number one so
the next person can come up and be
number one like I want to help everybody
and that's kind of what I get from
everybody who comes on black voices and
gaming but absolutely
yeah absolutely like you gotta pass the
plug and and help you out you know I'm
saying you can't gatekeep and stuff like
that you got to pass the plug now what
you do with it is is you know that's up
to you like what I mean but you got to
pass that plug so I'm with you on that
Big Time yeah yes and when you say
gatekeep absolutely we can't be doing
that in our culture we got we have to
the only way for us to actually make it
to the top as a group is to help each
other out as a group which is why black
voices in gaming is so important is why
we have you on here that's why we've had
red on here that's why but Justin and
Alfonso put this together is because
like we're here for y'all you know what
I'm saying we're here for the culture
and we're here to be seen and to be
heard and listen y'all are not gonna not
hear hip-hop gamer okay
all kinds of stuff yeah yeah like you
you ain't gonna Escape me I literally
just came off the plane today from New
Orleans I was just on ESPN uh yesterday
because uh we did a big program
um out there and uh we performed on the
actual court before tip-off for the
Pelicans and Dallas Mavericks game so
even with that we brought like five
inner city uh youth kids that's talented
in New Orleans it gave them their shine
too so we do this at the highest level
and we ain't just talking about it I can
show you everything you know I mean and
one thing I wanted to say that before
you go to your next question one thing I
wanted to say you said that uh
that um you know a lot of times it could
be overwhelming when a lot of people
keep telling you no a lot of people keep
telling you no
um here's just words I'm not saying you
gotta do this or anybody that's watching
it's just words of advice I would just
say but if people tell you no you got to
tell yourself yes
period you know what I'm saying like and
when you tell yourself yes then you
block out all the noise and go get it
done and then the same people that told
you no is going to be asking you
questions on how to be a part of your
yes
[Applause]
yeah
you know I mean and the thing is
everything I'm saying yeah like
everything I'm saying Destiny I'm living
proof for that so I ain't just saying it
because it sounds nice as a sound bite
right like you know what I'm saying like
I do this like so at the end of the day
I want people that's watching this to
when people tell you no that's fine
because your vision is for you they may
not get it that's cool and it doesn't
mean there's any ill will to it they
don't get it that's fine but if they
tell you no you tell yourself yes
because later on that no is going to
want to be a part of your yes remember
that
now that's facts and you're living proof
and you're living in your truth and I
appreciate that that is some of the best
advice that I've ever heard like it's
short simple but like so real at the
same time so I appreciate that I need
that advice so yeah I definitely know
that people out there will probably
appreciate hearing that and I'm all for
it so one of the questions I wanted to
ask about because we we kind of talked
about your wrestling belt which was what
I really wanted to know about we talked
about your gaming career let's jump into
your music career because listen that
video was fire like you are so talented
yeah
thank you very much so you know what's
interesting so on the music side of
things just to give you a bit of the
history I wasn't always who I am today
you know what I'm saying so I grew up
East New York Brooklyn Born and Raised
you know what I'm saying and um that was
a completely different environment for
real so what happened is they used to
call me Jack who flesh back in the day
they used to call me Jackal I was a
completely different person you know
what I'm saying everything was gangster
rap cursing here cursing here while
they're not ready to pop off it was
different right so my Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ changed my life my
grandmother helped bring me to that
point and one of the things that changed
my life was I used to work in the mail
room for all the record labels Def Jam
Rockefeller bloodline rest in peace DMX
uh uh you know Dip set you know
everywhere I worked in the Maryland
Universal Music Group all of that right
and I used to play my music in the mail
room there was this one guy I don't
remember his name it's such a long time
ago but I don't remember his name but
he's a tall dude
something like that and the thing is uh
he said yo you very intelligent why do
you always curse all the time like why
why make a song without cursing so I
always been the type of person that was
up for a challenge right so I made a
song without cursing and he was like yo
that's amazing now do it again now do it
again and then over time it made me
realize that wow like when I performed
like this I was no longer being edited I
didn't have to be edited because I'm
broadening my vocabulary I can just say
what I gotta say without having to edit
anything
and then the second thing is I started
to translate into my daily speech over
time you know what I'm saying so now in
my regular daily talking voice I don't
curse you know what I'm saying like you
know I don't I don't drink I don't smoke
I don't do any of these things I'm a
family brand and the thing is that
changed my life on that concept
is
when I got offered a record deal me and
my peoples me and my family my brothers
and stuff I was 14 years old and I
turned the deal down like MC Shan and
everything from back in the day the book
of bridge the book of book of prison
yeah deals like offered to me and I
turned it down because it didn't feel
right what I was about to step into so I
had a whole different purpose that I
didn't understand in in these moments so
fast forward to today I'm able to write
about music right uh with no write my
music about games uh write about
anything I don't use curse words
everything is positive and uplifting and
if I'm battling somebody I can still
battle somebody without being vile and
vulgar with it you know I have my own
style doing it so to me is a humbling
honor to do the music the way I want to
do it and put it in the every years that
I want to put it and utilize it as
another anchor to build my brand and
Inspire other people that yo same deal
that made a song for Watch Dogs 2 is the
same dude that was rapping you know
where she glutes from the Lots in the
Mailroom like you know what I'm saying
it's it's a different impact and I'm the
only one that can say that no in in the
culture right now so I'm very excited
about what's to come musically and um
stay tuned because I have something
already ready to go
is just a certain a certain time frame
when it's going to come out but I got
something that's going to surprise a lot
of people
let's just say hashtag let's just say
hashtag gamerskin rap
and I want to leave it at that okay
because it ain't just me yeah it ain't
just me shout out to Mega ran you know
what I'm saying shout out to my man Dan
Bull shout out to you know Richie
Branson there's others but Gamers can
rap and you're gonna see something
different
[Music]
yeah of course being a gamer and
listening to rap new yeah I mean like
you know you'd be sitting there gaming
and then you would have like DMX on or
you'd have to [__] off you'd have Big E
on in the background as you're playing
but having you be integrated into games
like this this is why I'm excited I'm
excited because it's not just
them taking our music and using it for
our like their games it's literally us
making the music at for the game so you
know what I'm saying and that's so so
important because you you have you have
that saying where it's just like they
like everything that we produce that
they just don't like us you know what I
mean yeah so this is like we're coming
up and we're showing that there's a huge
difference where you're opening doors
that have never been opened before and
that is incredible
and I want more people to walk in and I
just want more people to walk in and
Elevate because it's not look man you
can't do it by yourself you're not going
to find success by yourself and who
you're going to share with if you're by
yourself so it's like come on great
let's get it right and and I think one
of the things that's so important and
then we'll we'll wrap it up but you're
not stepping on other people to get to
the top and I think that's really
important I think a lot of people need
to understand that you do not have to
step on people you don't have to tear
people down to make your path or to
create your path to get where you want
to be and if you think you do we
literally have an example of someone who
has not done that and is here telling
you right now how he's done it what he's
continued to do and how he's opening
doors hoping more of you who might be
interested in getting into gaming
getting into music can walk through and
I yo that's so amazing that that's
amazing because you don't have a lot of
people who want to help other people out
and I think this is incredible and I'm
so happy yeah you're not as crazy
because people
yeah because a lot of times a lot of
times most people they operate out of
fear and scarcity you know what I'm
saying so if you operate out of fear and
scarcity you may hurt someone not
intentionally but you thinking about
yourself because you got to survive and
if it's me or you then you know you're
going to choose yourself and step on
somebody else just to get something and
I think that's foul you know what I'm
saying uh a lot of times people will put
you against somebody just to be able to
get further in your career then you got
to ask yourself where do you want your
career to go because it ain't gonna last
long like you can have a successful
moment or do you want to have a
successful longevity long uh enjoyable
career over time so you gotta remember
like 2008 okay
2023 and it's not stopping it feels like
it's just beginning all over again with
all the stuff that's going on now
secretly now secretly there's a lot of
people that like I helped out put on put
in position and there's a lot of people
that
um have benefited from things that carry
it because it's like y'all helping them
to your benefit but what about helping
them to their benefit it has to go
Mutual so there's a lot of things that's
changed behind the scenes that people
may not be aware of that I had a hand in
but what I will say is right now in this
climate I am ecstatic to see a lot of
people
starting to get theirs and get what they
deserve it is everything to me and I
always like yo well what do you need
what's your goals hit me up I know this
person boom or go here you need to be
here like yo it don't take away nothing
from me like you know what I'm saying
there's only like there's there's only
one hip-hop gamer go I do this at the
same time look it around you black
voices is black voices in gaming is the
name of this joint you know what I mean
out there like they got me mad things
popping off we supporting everything we
lit you know what I'm saying so I'm
going all out I'm like like fire fire
emoji on everything yeah yeah we moving
let's go so yep
oh my God I love it well that's it for
us we gotta wrap it up I could talk to
you all day we gotta connect red we
gotta connect tell her I said I love her
guys you you Denise said she loves you
with me
uh
but um just want to say thank you again
for coming on and sharing your knowledge
with us your words of wisdom because
they are so needed especially for the
young who are coming up and want to get
into the industry
anybody wants to find out more about you
your music what you're up to can you
drop your socials one more time yeah yo
Google me yo hip-hop game I'm everywhere
just Google me you type A hip-hop gamer
everything and that thing's mama and
sister and brother and cousin and Ray
Ray everybody at the barbecue is gonna
pop up when you type my name in all
right hip hop gamer the goat of the game
you know what I'm saying Hot 97 lots of
tech g-a-m-d and don't forget to get
that pledge black voices and gaming
Denise what up let's get it
yeah yeah thank you so so much guys this
has been an absolute president
talk to you again at some point hip-hop
gamer like oh my God that was incredible
but listen guys if you're enjoying what
you've seen so far if you've liked any
of the games if you've liked any of the
people that we've had come on please go
find their socials and go look them up
also if you want to help bvig you can
always help through donations through
our tiltify for black voices and gaming
because that goes towards our mission of
helping game Studio entrepreneurs
succeed and uh yeah listen that was that
was dope I need to calm down I need a
moment we'll be back in a bit
foreign
if you missed some of the dope
developers and games last month don't
worry we got you we're going to take a
look at some of the amazing titles our
developers are working on
[Music]
[Applause]
your friends
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
can you play something
for their friends and family
[Music]
thank you
you're this distraction machine
will it save our people or lead us to
ruin
Ed
foreign
[Music]
thank you
when I wake up
[Music]
baby
ease my mind
[Music]
money bags News Network probably
presents your number one source for your
current events of course with a little
of my comments every sprinkle that oh we
got a guest today before I bring them in
what's up
run by some time and since lifestyle to
Founders law enforcement so childish no
one is wrong but they won't do a damn
thing about it presidents gone a victim
of kidnapping we keep screaming and
still nothing happens
suplex a train anyway when we get back
from the break we gonna be someone who
has something important to say so grab a
little snack for something cold and just
chill to the next episode
[Music]
find out
all right
[Music]
cool
fly low Moon
highlight my hands getting cold long
nights we'll be all right sitting
selling a mess keeping King close see
the try going in what we hear from
throwing down let me hold a couple
arrows but a claim I'm Elaine let the
string go now we know we don't have time
not to fight
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
wow that was a really cool block of
trailers I'm really excited for all
those games I I'm again it shows just
like the breadth and depth of the space
right we get a chance to see so many
cool games that are going to be
hopefully in your hands very very soon
and get a chance to kind of check those
out Dez what are your thoughts about
that amazing kind of dope trailer block
that we got a chance to see
listen I am always super excited to see
any of the games that black voices and
gaming are are showcasing and I know we
got to see a trailer for a game that we
are going to be checking out in this
next interview which I'm super excited
about who are we checking out in the
next interview because I know you know
who is like tell the people absolutely
we get to bring our friend Joseph Hooker
to the stage to talk about trigger and
talk about this wonderful game that's
coming into the space Joseph let's
welcome you to the stage and get to hear
more from you about all of the work that
you're doing in the space and how how
you got here
yeah uh hi I'm Justin flicker I am a
developer out of Oakland uh we're
currently working on
um arcade shooter uh I started out uh
just as a kid in high school
um making video games as part of the
social outreach program
um and I got hooked up with a Justin
um along the way and he's been helping
me hone my skills and and
make releasing this a reality
so I'm super hyped for this because this
fills all those kind of aesthetic needs
that I need that I have this reminds me
of so many games that I played as as a
youngster and now you know kind of being
a little bit older getting a chance to
to get some of those retro Vibes uh talk
to us a little bit about trigger and and
and how we how you thought about this
game uh coming to the space
yeah yeah I uh started out like
my first games I ever played were on uh
the main emulator I played Galaga on
asteroids on my on my dad's computer and
so I've always kind of had like
um an interest in classic arcade games
um and so uh coming into like on my
first like solo game that I ever wanted
to make I decided that I wanted it to be
something that kind of scratched that
itch for me
um and also uh felt like how I would do
it given what I know now and kind of the
the modern techniques that I can be
deployed uh now that we've kind of come
so far in the games industry
nice so I had a question for you I know
that like you you
developer game fund and you mentioned
like meeting Justin and like him kind of
mentoring you how did that come about
how did you meet Justin that like we
don't get these stories a lot but how
did you guys connect
yeah uh I I was part of the uh the game
heads program out of the Bay Area
um and then during one of the early
showcases uh Justin came around to see
some of the games and he saw like a very
early prototype of trigger and said he
was interested in helping me uh get it
out in the world
so we're watching some gameplay uh
currently uh we got Dez on the sticks
um go through a little bit of info for
folks at home who are just getting a
chance to see this for the first time
about what the game experience is what
the loop is and and how they can best
kind of get there get their score up in
the game
yeah uh so the the court game loop as we
started was just like a very simple uh
ship that can uh turn and then shoot
different colors
um uh tournament is like with the
shoulder pads and student colors is
ascribed to like each individual button
on a controller so like uh red is the uh
green is a new list X
um and your goal is just it's a it's an
infinite wave uh arcade shooter so you
just keep fighting enemies uh until you
can anymore
all right so you gotta you got to tell
me Dez how's the game feel how are
things moving you're you're doing you're
wrecking it right now
um I'm just you know what this is not
the type of game I usually I'm coming
from farming and uh gambling to saving
the universe
just doing my best
so
oh okay so talk again about the color
changes in in the game and what they
represent for the folks at home yeah so
uh each enemy uh will spawn with uh a
given color and
um well you can hurt them with uh like
um a color that doesn't match you're
gonna get the most uh points and the
most and the most uh the most uh drops
by doing color matching so hit the enemy
hit the red enemy with the red shot hit
the green I need the green shot with
Blue at me
um got it okay okay so that's that that
brings in so many different versions or
kind of you know permutations on how you
can kind of play the game and get the
best effect once you're kind of already
on the sticks and you talked a little
bit about Galaga being a inspiration
here what were or some other games you
played you know throughout throughout
your your game playing time that really
kind of uh informs trigger and what
you're trying to build
yeah I mean like obviously uh ikoruga
um yes zero Ranger uh that's kind of a
newer one uh that I I really loved uh
playing that uh oh my god
um I just realized that the colors
correlate with the buttons on my
controllers
no I love that
um yeah uh and then
uh there's some like uh Soho uh that's
kind of a deeper cut for for those who
are in in the
the top dancing
um
yeah and then
um I was also inspired by like a lot of
uh milk lights
um so there's there's like an upgrade
system after you uh defeat a boss
um
that will modify
um how you can play the game so like if
you're maybe maybe not all that good at
color matching for instance for example
um there are certain upgrades that'll
um
yeah the green things are healthy
listen y'all this is not my first time
playing the game whatever
[Music]
desol so far I mean you're rocking it
right now you're getting it you're
getting it I mean like the fact that I
haven't died yet I'm not gonna say I'm a
professional at it
oh I love this this gives me so many
Vibes of games that I just loved playing
as as a kid and you know there's some
early early Xbox games that I remember
being very close to this too like uh
yeah why can't I think of it right now I
just fell off my tongue but I but I
played so many hours of that game for
the folks also here's a cool question
for you in a game that has color
matching like this or do you have any
options in there or you're working on
the options for accessibility stuff for
like color blindness and things like
that too
yeah yeah
um I have systems in place right now
that are going to allow for uh both
changing the colors themselves
um that are that are present in the game
so if you wanted to make red an entirely
different color that's a possibility for
you
um as well as
um having just like preset modes for uh
the different kinds of color blindness
so that like certain colors will be like
uh closer to White than the actual cause
himself so like if you have red green
colorblindness I can I can switch uh the
color uh like green to White
um
uh using a press processing effect so
that's awesome to differentiate better
yeah that's super cool so how long have
you been working on the game again
uh I've been working on it on and off uh
while I've been uh like if you're under
school for about like four years now oh
yeah and then here's the operating
system I like this oh this is cool did
you turn
you can uh choose yeah pick which ones
oh
that's cool I like that okay I'm gonna
go with that one just for the visual
aesthetic persist yeah like even the
visual aesthetic of that just really
made me happy that's super cool I just
like that yeah it's very very clean in
that in that respect too
uh blue
what has been the kind of most um
interesting thing that you found out
about the development process during
your your time making this game I think
everybody you know once you've made a
game or you're starting to make your
first game or even your second or third
you end up pulling away with some some
tidbits of things that you learned that
kind of influence the next layer of
development what has that been like for
you especially as you're doing this not
full time you're doing this kind of you
know in between you know your schooling
and things like that
yeah uh I I learned that it's like it's
very
like when you're working on a game like
this it's it's a lot about like
what you don't include then what you do
include so
um
like a lot of this is about restraint
like not like going overboard because
it's it's trying to hearken towards
certain things in certain Aesthetics and
so a lot of this has been like me adding
something and then like going okay does
this does this contribute to what I'm
going for or does this is this like uh
overloading the player overloading the
aesthetic
um and and kind of clashing a bit and
like kind of going through that process
over and over again until I have
something that I'm having
that's fantastic conversation
[Laughter]
there's any findings that you have it's
just totally fine I got questions on
questions uh we'll let you handle it
also this has real really fantastic
music talk a little bit about that too
because I think that's a driver for
games like this in a real way
yeah yeah uh I had an awesome uh
composer come in and uh be able to uh
uh developed um some composing music for
me uh called telling ways
um and and he he just was able to pick
it up on the the vibe I was going for
from from my initial documents uh like
from the jump so it's been it's been
very
um
very nice to be able to just like have
have that opportunity to work with
someone like that
um and then as well like with with just
other artists
um
being able to like work on them with
with my vision for something
yeah I love that and also the name of
the game tracker is a play on on trigger
is that is that is that the call there
yeah yeah it's like triple trigger
yeah I like that a lot that's super
super cool
oh my goodness this is fantastic I I'm
very very excited about getting my hands
on this and getting a chance to play
this any any last thoughts about you
know the process of of kind of going
through and making this or again one of
the things that you want to pull for for
the player who who's gonna be checking
this out
um
yeah sure uh I I would say like the the
point of of the game is to try to be
hard and to be a bit
um
uh so like I I would definitely say go
into this with the mindset of like it's
it's designed to piss you off of foot
some points because that's like that's
what I'm trying to get at is kind of
that that classic like quarter eating
machine kind of thing
um I like the back of the box quote
bound to piss you off
[Laughter]
but I love that again like I think games
like this they they they give me that
old school feel and I that I miss a lot
I I'm a big uh you know score Hunter
quarter muncher kind of person when it
comes to games like this it feels very
much like a game that that speaks to
that old school arcade feel
um and just the aesthetic too just has a
lot of that I remember this that
asteroids
kind of vibe right and you know those
geometric shapes kind of pulling through
and being the enemies that you have to
fight through to get to the scores that
you want to get to if of all the folks
you've had a chance to kind of you know
test this and play with it
give me give me the goods who who's the
best so far who's who's the person who
we have to look out for on the on the
leaderboards to make sure that we're
taking them down is it you or is it Dez
yeah
yeah you've been pretty good uh so far I
think
um I've I've been the one that's been
that's been doing the oh the the best uh
I will say that like
um more recently I've had other like but
other people from the Knicks be able to
get on it um and and there's a guy Andre
uh who's who's been able to quickly kind
of get up the leaderboard and and uh
very much uh challenge me a bit
um
so so Andre huh we got we gotta come for
Andre we got we gotta get Andre off the
boards yeah yeah
I'm gonna be practicing so I can get up
there with you and Andre I'm you know
what I'm not gonna lie I'm proud of
myself I thought I was gonna die and I
got to like the third the third wave I
know you know yeah
it's actually a lot of fun and I do
remember like y'all this is like old
school but going to the laundromat
because there was always arcade machines
there with my grandmother and like
playing these type of games like snake
and stuff and like it definitely like if
you were trying to pull on some
Nostalgia some Nostalgia strings you you
got it with this game absolutely awesome
awesome you've sold me I'm I am ready to
get down and take Andre out of here I
gotta get Audrey done out of here you're
not ready
I'm taking him taking the spot from you
uh we're gonna we're gonna make it
happen in a real way uh Justin before we
let you go uh give the folks at home a
little bit more information about where
they can find out more about the game or
about what you're working and more about
try Gary in general
yeah yeah
um you can find me at uh at Joe devs on
Twitter uh and there there isn't gonna
be a lot about that like right now uh
but there's gonna be more coming out
um after it after we do a mixed showcase
at GDC
um so yeah stay tuned for for updates on
that uh yeah
awesome awesome Joseph thank you so much
for being with us today so excited to
hear more I'm finally gonna get some
hands on with this now you said it's
going to be a GDC that's going to be
fantastic
again Andre I'm coming for you taking
you taking you
team BVI Genie right right you guys will
see it in the scores right there just
see bvig in there and they're gonna be
like what happened
uh thank you again Joseph for rocking
with this uh Dez any any of the last
thoughts for Joseph before letting go
listen I think I think this game is
incredible I had a lot of fun when I
first started it I was like oh man
this is not my type of game I'm gonna
embarrass myself on screen but now it
was fun and um just you know proud of
you and your your creativity and the
work that you put in always always and
thank you for coming on to bvig thank
you for telling us how like you met
Justin and like how that all came about
because these are the kind of stories
that we want to share when we do our
showcase so yeah good luck to you and
all your future endeavors
very very cool that was Joseph Hooker
everybody for coming and bringing us
trigger to check out uh I'm very very
excited because now I have another score
Chaser game to play games like this are
the ones that like those are like my
before I go to bed games where people
are like don't play anything special
before you go to bed I love to play
games that are a little bit stressful
before they go to bed it really calms me
down
I watch horror movies before I go to bed
I play stressful video games but because
I I just don't I don't care about my
life but
it was dope to see you rocking you did a
really good job on on playing thank you
getting to level three
I want everybody to know that was my
first time playing I know I sound
facetious right now but for real for
real that was my first time like I was
my first time playing so I'm pretty
proud of that it wasn't like you know
Animal Crossing where it's just easy
like there's some skill actually playing
the game makes me feel like I'm a better
gamer So for anybody who has anything to
say you know watching I hope you saw
that okay watch that Andre that's all I
did you saw I just rocked it watch out
Andre coming for you wherever you may be
but guys we still have so much more to
show you but don't forget to check out
our steam store and don't forget to wish
list all the games that you've seen on
today's showcase as well as those that
you've seen in the past
and uh I'm pretty excited because we
have a new guest coming up she's
incredible she's done so much for the
Gaming Community we're going to watch a
quick video but uh let's get it rolling
for letter j
it's the grand opening for coexist game
this commercial spot right here on 38th
Street between 9th and 8th and it's late
the energy in here is amazing if you're
walking in a completely different world
it's like a gaming Club in New York
where people can come content creators
and music people and just connect it's
really dope there's a whole party going
on oh man if you're a gamer you would
definitely love this place there's like
all these classic games that you can
play they have over 2 000 games like
from a Neo Geo Super Nintendo on the
first floor there's a bunch of arcade
games in the back we have the Citadel
people are chilling in the lounge
upstairs we have tournaments NBA 2K 22
they have a bottom floor with like a
lounge they got ping pong downstairs
they have the big Uno cards people
performing and stuff like that they have
a studio like I'm into music so that was
super dope for me coexist is a place
where creatives come together it's games
it's music it's art it's a lot of
creatives coming in one space really
enjoying the company of people who they
would have never met outside of a space
like this people who will never co-exist
outside can step in these doors and meet
a whole nother branch of friends that
they probably would not have connect
with outside I'm the type of person I
see you walking on the street and in my
head I want to be your friend but I'm
like we're in New York we don't do that
and coexist you can do that you meet
people and they have the same energy and
it just builds as a collective I think
this is a good spot for anybody who's
not even a gamer because you can chill
you can drink you can Vibe Network
everyone has a space here at
coexistaming even if you don't play
games there's still like a chance to
connect with people I met two girls here
and I'm like oh how long have you guys
known each other and like we just met
here and now we're a group of people
hanging out and I'm sure at some point
we'll collab on music this is the place
for that kind of energy to consistently
be that way I've never felt anything
like this before it's all love here I
feel like everyone's trying to meet
people for genuine like connections
we're gonna Vibe and we're gonna talk
and call just let it all come together
in one spot
[Music]
oh also you have people that will bust
my ass in Smash Bros so that's too
[Music]
so incredible and I know you talked
about touring in Japan I used to live in
Korea for like five years so I've been
to Japan a couple of times and like just
the I I totally understood what you were
talking about walking in and just losing
yourself because there's so much going
on in those spaces and I think one of
the places I went to uh was in Okinawa
and it was like this gaming bar so when
I saw coexist I was like yo food games
yes people who look like you which is so
important loving the same things you do
is just I love that you're putting this
together I can't believe you're playing
listen I was excited about coexist but
now you're saying you've got a a
magazine coming out with cosplay and
that's really important just because I
feel like black cosplayers don't get
enough recognition and because they get
hated on a lot for cosplaying characters
they like and it's just ridiculous so I
love that you're showcasing that can you
tell me a little more about this
convention because um I want to go and
I'm sure everybody else who's watching
wants to go so please like give us more
details about that of course well so I
mean one of the one of the biggest
Milestones that I've reached is bringing
we had we ended up having three
locations in Brooklyn and they were all
residential spaces so literally two
duplexes in a townhouse because we kept
outgrowing them but they also served
different purposes the goal was to
finally get to our first commercial
space which we did at the end of last
year
um so we have this beautiful three level
space uh a little under 4 000 square
feet right in the heart of just Midtown
Manhattan steps from Times Square and
the goal is to bring back that
convention that we started with in the
first place this this amazing experience
it's a two but this is going to be a
two-day con so Saturday and Sunday 12 to
12 where it's just it's every it's all
the things we love
um one of the really cool things that we
did in the competitive scene was we took
you know normally you'll you'll go to
like a 2K tournament or you'll go to
like OverWatch and everybody's there to
see that particular game but we would
have an itinerary of five to seven
tournaments happening in one day so like
three o'clock there's someone Tech in
the PlayStation Lounge 2ks down over
here Smashes in the Nintendo Lounge we
had Connect Four tournaments like really
cool stuff for casual gamers too and it
was so inclusive that what was happening
is people that were only seeing people
that they normally streamed they
actually saw them in real time so we
were really bringing communities
together and there were so many so many
gamers are creative right so we were
having did dance battles we did live
performances we did cosplay fashion
shows we have anime trivia
um and then now it's just kind of like
up in the Annie you know so everything
is just another level we actually did
kind of a really special event that was
the precursor to the code
we had Chuck Hoover voice over actor
come through who plays tons of
characters on my hero Academia Naruto
and Hunter Hunter so yeah it was so dope
so this is why I was excited at dice I
met uh Chris judge who plays Kratos and
yeah
and we're I'm trying to get him to come
to a Cod and so he texted him like oh my
God I'm like
foreign
I know I'm really excited to bring kind
of like you know I tell I tell everyone
we are inclusive right we were inclusive
we don't turn anyone away but of course
I would be remiss as a woman of color
not to highlight and support and
represent us we need that support and so
one of the most exciting things that I'm
excited about the con is that we're
doing an entire area for Developers so
now the developers don't have to be
separated from the rest of the community
I want to bridge the gap between Esports
and development and this is what that
looks like
oh my god look I think you're doing so
many amazing things not only are you are
here black voices and gaming talking
about it but you're out there doing it
in your own way and I love the message
of togetherness that really like it just
encompasses the whole thing that you're
doing which is really beautiful because
I think uh within the industry there's
there's times that we really separate
ourselves like oh you're not a true
gamer or you only play this like type of
game and it's it just doesn't matter
like people should enjoy games the way
they enjoy it anime cosplay and so all
right
I know this event is happening
yes I'm very excited like I'm like
shaking excited because I I want to go
where can we find out more information
and keep up to date with just all the
things that you're doing all the things
with coexist like how do we find that
information if we want
yes so right now everything's available
on our website you go to
coexistgaming.com and there's a tab for
events on the home page so we're
actually announcing the con at the top
of next week
um April 1st the second are the dates I
know so I'm really I'm really excited
you know it's the first one and we just
want we just want the community to come
out support meet Network experience
everything come in their best cosplay
and just really
I'm gonna tell you this the most
exciting part for me is that it's a
monthly con
so every month okay
a two-day card so it's just a really
dope opportunity to continue building
Community like we always have
no you shouldn't have to wait once a
year right we shouldn't have to and I
love that you're doing it once a month
because like if I I think that just
makes it accessible which is really
important right because not everybody
can go at a certain time of the year but
if you do it all year long like that's
incredible because when you said April I
was like how am I gonna make this work
but now that I know
I'm so excited for it
listen I just I wanted to I know we we
don't really know each other but like
from from this point on you're about to
be bestie like you're gonna be in my top
five clearly clearly
yes but I want to say from one black
female Creator and and being in the
industry how proud I am of your
successes and that like I truly truly
hope that you reach all the goals that
you want to reach because I can see
right now that like you're not just
doing it for you you're doing it for the
culture and the community and just
there's just not enough of us doing that
so I I am super proud of you thank you
thank you and I just think that's
incredible yeah I know
but guys listen please if you want to
find out more about the cons which she
just dropped they're happening once a
month so this is incredible
um and you want to find out more about
coexist or you just want to find out
more about letter and her music which
I'm gonna I'm gonna jump on in just a
second because I do want to talk about
your music that is a huge part of your
life do not forget to check out their
website so before we wrap it up
can you tell me a little bit about your
music Journey because
um I know we've talked about coexisting
but I feel like music is so ingrained
into Black Culture that like we we have
to talk about that I could not inter
like I couldn't in the interview without
you telling me a little bit more about
your journey in the music world
whoa it it feels like it's been so long
because I've been singing I've been
singing since I was a little girl I
started playing the violin the viola the
cello when I was five and the alto sax
when I was nine and the piano when I was
12 and then the guitar when I was 15 and
performing at UIL competitions I was
classically trained I used to sing opera
and all of that and so it's been a
really big part of my life
um and so I moved to New York and signed
my first record deal it's been years ago
now but
that I'm just I'm all of the lessons
I've learned like the music I created so
when I was signed at a Motown I was
actually kind of a pop rock artist so my
tours have always been International
um and most like I'm dropping a single
this year and I'm very excited about it
actually I'm so a lot of people don't
know but like I'm Dominican and so it's
funny because there's this meme where
you're like hanging with your black
friends and then they find out you
Dominican too
you're like Benicio Mommy and they're
like I don't even know you you know
but it's funny because this song is in
English and Spanish and so it's called
Patron which means uh boss in Spanish
and so it's very much a trivia a tribute
to women and just like empowering like
Empower empowering boss I I don't know
if it curse on here I was about to say a
parent class you know please
exactly but just everything is like it's
a very powerful song lyrically even
though it's in English and Spanish and
something that I just want uh you know
to just kind of it's like where I'm at
right now and just and so I'm I'm
excited that I feel more free musically
than I have you know because record
labels are changing but they are just
not the most supportive of your creative
journey in terms of it's just a tough
it's a tough game and so I you know
every creative wants to
be able to make a living off of doing
what they love
but you don't want to have to deal with
men who abuse their power and their
positions of authority and it is a
really unfortunate part of that industry
so I I sort of set out on this path to
just create opportunities for people
through music and thankfully gaming
allows me to do that too so I created
our coexist music MonDay program it's
kind of interesting how I literally
redirected everything I love into gaming
because gaming is like development
particularly as creative as it is
technical so I get to be an engineer I
get to be a recording artist I get to be
a competitive gamer I get to be a you
know a chef I get to be a Psalm I get to
be all the things that I am
unapologetically
authentically and
I get to show other people that they can
too and and that's my life's work it's
the most fulfilling thing to me in the
world I'm really grateful that's what's
up oh my God you were just a jewel I I'm
so serious I wish we could we I could
talk to you for like ever but I know
a lot yeah we have to talk offline
because I I want to help however I can
because I'm all about representation and
inclusion
um what did Jay thank you so much for
coming on today and sharing a part of
your journey guys do not miss out go
check her out she if you don't
understand how dope she is just from the
20 minutes you got to listen to her I
don't know what to tell you but yeah
thank you so much for coming on and um
don't be a stranger yeah I won't
you know the energy yes
[Laughter]
I feel it it's like listen I I grew up
loving Jim and the Holograms and I
totally felt that right then like you
are the Synergy is there but before we
drop off really quickly one more time
where can people find you drop your
socials so we can keep up with what
letter J is up to yes so you can hit me
directly at letter J music that's
l-e-t-t-a J music but of course you need
to follow everything coexist so it's
coexistgaming on Instagram uh coexist
you so coexist gaming GG on Twitter but
if you go to our website all of our
links to all the platforms are actually
at the top and bottom of the website
we'd love to coexist with you pull up
holla at your girl let's keep the
progress moving forward
Jay has been such an incredible guest
and we have more guests coming up so
I actually we don't have any more guests
coming up you are we saved the best for
Less you are actually our last guest
oh I love that I'm honored and I had an
amazing
no thank you all right so guys
we're about to do our wrap up we're
gonna bring Khalif back and he's going
to help me out as we basically end our
show with the Banger so we'll see you in
just a second
yo that was incredible I'm always super
amazed at the talent and all the hard
work that goes into developing these
games and just making moves in the
industry on their own like that's the
Jay's story with like coexist is
incredible I want to go to New York like
have that here
um Khalif tell me what did you think
about the show what do you think about
our guest again it's one of the things I
love about bvig is that we get a chance
to see all these amazing devs and all
these folks from all these corners of
the world talk about the experiences and
how they're making games better it is
one of the best things on the planet and
just so excited that I got a chance to
be a part of it and rock with all of you
at home Jay was amazing's aloe vera
fantastic Gerald continues to kill her
with everything that he does so uh just
we got a really Banger of a show today
for sure we really did and that's what's
up and you know what before we go into
thinking everyone again I want to thank
you the viewer and those of you have
taken the time to donate to our tiltify
it means so much to us like we really
really appreciate it and um yeah that's
from the bottom of my heart and all the
developers and and I'm sure I can speak
on Khalif like we're all just like
really thankful thank you thank you I
know that seems like sarcastic but it's
not I really do want you to know that
like you're special and we appreciate
all your views your likes your thumbs
ups and your shares but um
we are at the end of the show and what
we like to do at the end of the show is
throw another thank you and show our
appreciation to all those who have
helped us get here where we are today so
let's roll it with the sponsors
our partners for today's showcase listen
like we said
Playstation Silver sponsor I have been
rocking with PlayStation forever I Still
Rock my PS3 I don't care what anybody
says
I'll be watching Netflix YouTube playing
games all kinds of stuff do you have any
of your old systems Colleen I do I do
have a PS3 it's it's in my house
somewhere rocking collecting dust but
bringing home memories it's great I love
the PlayStation brand for sure
I got my first Xbox last year and as I
said earlier listen I'm just waiting for
my way to wakanda my way through all the
games and the Black Panther one because
it's so dope and also can I just say
y'all are doing the thing Xbox like the
whole custom thing is dope and um Khalif
didn't say he wanted one but Khalif
wants one too so I'm just saying I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna lie
for wakanda forever Edition just showed
up at my doorstep I wouldn't take it I
would I'd be right right
and shout out to me today oh yeah yeah
also riot
Riot thank you so much listen I know I
said I was trash at your games but I
think you guys have done an amazing job
not to mention that League of Legends is
one of the first games with like true
accessibility for free play for all
players the only things you're playing
for are like Aesthetics and that doesn't
even affect your game so that's really
dope because they're the first ones to
kind of do that so I didn't say that
earlier but you are doing the thing also
we'd like to thank our other sponsors
raw Fury we couldn't do this without
your help Razer if you love PC gaming
like I do it razors easily in my top
three and Wilson
suncini I listen every time I say that
name
I get really hungry for pasta it's just
it's it just rolls off the tongue but
their legal firm looking to get some
action in the video game sector and
listen we we welcome you because we need
that as as we're growing we definitely
need people who are helping us legally
we also want to say thanks to the mix
team and media one they have continued
to break barriers and build foundation
for Indie developers and it's been an
amazing journey to watch but Khalif I
know you wanted to add some stuff in
here so I'm gonna throw it to you I've
talked too much already I mean we got we
got to give some love as well to our
broadcasting partners because they help
us bring this show to all of you at home
so we have to give love to our folks
from twitch gaming IGN steam Gamespot
and game Joel it is fantastic to be able
to do this work alongside all of them if
you are watching the show right now
please please please go check out our
steam event page as well don't forget to
check that out at the mix event page on
Steam where you can go and learn more
about the bvig titles you can buy some
of those available games or you can add
them to your wish list as well and
wishlists help the devs a ton so make
sure you go and add the games you might
have seen today on there as well uh and
before we go we got to talk about all
the wonderful folks who are are donating
and giving us some love on the merch and
social sides one of the amazing things
that we get to do here black voices and
gaming is that you know we go from a
showcase to to a non-profit it's been
great to kind of build this out and and
get bigger and be able to do that work
which is helping so many developers
reach their dreams in creating and
releasing their own game so if you want
to help and support some of the devs
that you've seen in some of the games
you've seen today uh please go check out
our other showcases and be sure to go
over there uh and go check out the bvig
gaming tiltify page as well so make sure
you're donating on that side of the
fence too if you want to go out and get
some more dope drip too you got to go
check out the bvig shirts I need one in
the 3x I need that because I'm a chunky
boy
into the mix as well so if you want to
go to the merch spot go check that out
as well and before we go if you've got
to give us some love on socials give it
up to our our friends over at bvig the
family is here you can follow black
voices and gaming at bvig gaming on
Twitter at black voices and gaming on IG
and everywhere else you can go check out
the work that we do at black voices and
gaming.org so does it has been so dope
to be able to do this with you I have to
give a massive amount of love and shout
outs to entire pvig team for letting me
Rock today uh you know how much I love
working with all of y'all I want to
continue to uplift as many folks as we
possibly can so so thank you all for for
having me and doing it for the culture
I'm just honored to be you know in the
mix you know pun intended uh in terms of
of all that how that goes um and if you
want to catch up with more of the work
that I get a chance to do in the gaming
space please go make sure you check out
spawn on me but we're on all podcast
platforms as well check out khalifadams
on Twitter uh and yeah we have our third
annual Spanish Awards you'll be able to
see that in early 2024 so make sure
you're checking that out nice I'll be
there I will try to be there I want to
be there but uh
folks that's it for our showcase today
but before we go like I said I wanted to
thank you the viewer for being here and
rocking with us I hope you enjoyed
yourself because I know Khalif and I had
a blast introducing some new games
developers and people making moves in
the industry doing their own thing if
you saw a game today that piqued your
interest be sure to go wish list it
follow the developers and our other
guests on their social media platforms
and hit us up and tell us what you
thought
remember that bvig isn't just a showcase
but it's now a non-profit so if you'd
like to support us and the developers
head on over to the tiltify and donate
no amount is too small and we truly
appreciate it you're helping us to make
sure that black developers can be seen
and heard representation matters and
that's why we're working so hard to make
sure that you see us and you hear us
as always it's been a pleasure my name
is Destiny and you can find me at dnbc32
over at Twitter or check me out over at
Double XP which is a podcast at level
one gaming where I'll be chilling with
the family thanks so much for joining us
today happy gaming and we'll catch you
next time
foreign
[Music]
thank you